this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon and welcome to a stripey
start to our sunset Safari on a rather
windy afternoon it is a little bit
breezy Archer but still a beautiful day
as the cards have separated from this
morning and we've got a bit of sunshine
my name is Kristen on camera I've got a
Craig and we are coming to you live from
a South Africa which means that we would
love to hear from all of you remember
that you can get hold of us if you would
like to ask any questions or have any
comments we'll just want to well say
hello and you can do that on hashtag
Safari live on Twitter now it is willed
elephant day today so we shall be
probably doing all things elephant
related at this rate we're going to try
see if we can find an elephant herd I
know Steve had some this morning that
we're moving in a sort of south westerly
direction from central so we need to
check turn dams quickly and then we'll
come up to Milwaukee and hope that they
may be in there after the wind started
often elephants do you go into a
drainage section so we look for them I
will discuss all things elephant and
then after all of that so we'll probably
try and do a loop around try and see if
we can pick up those tandy until our
armored tracks as well as see waiting
garner ended up I have a sneaky
suspicion that maybe just maybe husana
is on a kill somewhere and ting ganas
using his nose to try and find it and
who knows maybe it's all of them
together which would be quite nice so
that's the plan for this afternoon but
before we do any of that we stumbled
upon a zebra that is well doing what we
are doing and sitting in the shade and
just enjoying the peace and quiet of
this beautiful Sunday afternoon it's
just sitting you're very easy now it's
not alone there are some others that are
around but they are a little bit further
away and up the slope towards quarantine
this guy is just taking it very easy a
few stamps of the feet and flicks of the
tail as flies land around the nether
regions which is quite common for many
of our antelopes unfortunately the flies
can be a bit of a nuisance to these guys
and so you'll often see their tails
wagging like that and them stomping
their feet
particularly when they're just resting
like this so this is the way that they
do rest very common to find zebras sits
or standing should I say in shady
sections in the afternoon just waiting
for the heat of the day to pass a little
bit before they then start to go and
graze and start to try and find some
food what you'll also find is that
they've probably been drawn here because
they want to go and drink either they
have already drunk or they're going to
go and drink at the pan in front of camp
and so that's why they're just waiting
for it to get a little bit cooler before
they go out into the blazing sunshine
and go and quench their thirst before
heading up onto Quarantine where it's
going to be much safer now I would
imagine that most of these zebras are
well aware that lions are in the area
this morning when I was sitting in the
tent on nest cam duty it was a cacophony
of noise coming from the northern side
of wee Attila I will actually inside
waffles hook but there were a lot of
lines calling this morning and from what
I gather the in calmer pride mates up
with the Evoque of ales and there was
lions all over the place everybody
apparently is accounted for and fine but
there was lots and lots of noise coming
from the northern side so let's see if
maybe just maybe they come south the
wind is blowing from the southern a
direction which will drag those Lions
back in this direction and so hopefully
this evening they might make an
appearance too now talking about lions
and talking about windy I know brain
clear Smith this morning headlines and
winter let's see if he still has them
here in the Maasai Mara
all we can see is a poor while the
sausage tree pride rests on a little
rocky outcrop under some Croton thickets
my name is Brent deer Smith and I have
the migrating wildebeest Veeam
on camera and Lions that are very much
asleep under bushes there's been quite a
lot of movement of all the beasts and
whatnot pasture today but they haven't
managed to get up off their lazy behind
but we are hoping at some point that
mass of animals that was around them
this morning does edge a little closer
remember this is a hundred percent live
and you can send through your questions
using the hashtag Safari live for now
the Lions are still snoozing
just a poor visible
very tired kitties Eakins we're actually
quite grateful the wind has literally
been howling the whole day it is only
recently stopped probably about 10
minutes ago that it's actually calm dial
I think the mountain look at that geez
and even realize that is a pile of dust
we're not going to say that's quite
grace but the amount of dust that is in
view in my eyes at the moment and the
justice who's our Mara Ranger who's out
with us is absolutely phenomenal I mean
yeah we've changed color with the amount
of dust that's blown over us over the
day but that's one of the things if you
want to get the good shots you got to
play the patience game I can just yeah
the faint no no no of a wildebeest
somewhere behind us I'm trying to see
where they are
so there are few zebra around of all the
beasts obviously behind us somewhere but
even there mooing can't wake up the
sausage tree pride just yet and let's go
to someone who could wake up the dead
James Henry
says he says he could wake up the dead
I've seen people climb out of their
graves and run away at the sound of
Brent Lea Smith on the March anyway
hello everybody welcome to Sunday
afternoon Sunday Safari here sunset
safaris what I meant at this part of
Juma we are trying to find should rule
the four year old Duchess of the West
she's Lepidus who we saw here this
morning my name is James Henry
there we go and on camera today is David
hello David
yeah we are we are doing our level best
to see if we can find some signs of the
slippered but I have found no tracks as
yet it is a glorious afternoon albeit a
little blustery but this is expected in
August please do talk to us of course
using the hashtag Safari live all the
chat stream on YouTube either will do be
lovely to hear from you but only go
my total species count for the afternoon
so far in terms of animals is one fly
which I'm going to try and kill the next
time it lands on my face I think I
missed it hasn't been entirely
successful now I don't think we'll do a
live action broad cost of that Thank You
Emma now of course you do
his name is termite mound and so we're
looking on all the termite mounds
because that apparently is where she
likes to hang out I haven't spent long
enough with her to know whether or not
that is true but it also it's quite
blustery now I know that brent was
talking about the wind and the Mara and
really is amazing how much it does blow
in the Mara but this month
specifically here it does blow quite a
lot as well not quite as much as in the
Mara but what it means is that the
tracks of animals quite difficult to
follow after day of blowing but I
haven't found any of her tracks now what
she did this morning was she came in
from the west down and then she sort of
cut down the north-south cut line that
separates her territory from tandy
standee of course is our 12 year old
queen of Juna lives to the eastern side
of Juma and she was quite purposefully
marking but then she also sort of
settled into a bit of scrub hare hunting
so I wasn't really sure whether she was
hunting or marking which was her
priority which means that when we left
her the bad hop was dead this morning
she could either have gone down to
ground she could have carried on and
walked quite a long way in her continued
territorial patrol so I'm really not
sure at this stage what she did
and three some tracks will let us know
or even better still there will be the
caucus of a recently killed and very
unfortunate antelope hanging from a tree
somewhere nearby
that would be good they would just look
on top of that termite mound if you
wouldn't mind the far one there let us
have a look I will train my binoculars
on it I'm pretty sure we spotted a bush
we have she isn't even a bush it's a
grass tuft testing so it was not to spot
a grass tuft on Sunday afternoons Sunday
grass tuft
you do get an impression of how dry it
is getting oh I see we're back on me
thank you very much for that David and
he's sitting on the radio sorry about
that
okay let's get going
oh no I don't think so Jennifer I think
that the competition that we sort of
insinuated as that exists between Tandy
and shadaloo is not in fact real anymore
I think it was to start with I think but
they've very nicely settled up their
territories they may come to blows if
one of them tries to expand into the
other's territory but I don't see why
they would do that she do lose occupied
territory to the west of Tandy's the old
territory of shadow and who was Tandy
sister and of course Tandy has occupied
a mother's cherishing her ULA's
territory here in the central parts of
Jummah and as long as they're doing
their territorial patrols and marking
along the way there's no reason for them
to try and expand into each other's
territories and have some sort of
physical confrontation I suppose the
only conditions under which that would
happen would be a severe drought eat to
go on extraterritorial hunting forays
the size of a cat's territory is almost
exclusively defined by the amount of
prey in the area so if you go to very
dry areas like the Kalahari or even
drier you will find that the leopard
territories are probably up to ten times
the size of the territories here and if
you go down onto the Sand River which is
not too far from here of course where
the game is even denser than it is where
we are now you'll find that the
territories are even smaller than they
are here I suppose not almost exclusive
that its prey density but certainly prey
density makes a huge difference in an
area of homogeneous vegetation
right now I've got the following
instruction we're going to go to Taylor
apparently who has got something in the
praying of the Kenyan now I don't know
what that means the praying in the
Kenyan perhaps there's something to do
with Sunday well we did
we've never switched it up because
Archie well he wants to film everything
this afternoon we have a crocodile but
we'll show you some of the prey species
in a little while hello everybody so
there's just wave awkwardly so my name
strap comes up my name is Taylor and I'm
camera with me today is Archie and here
we have a safari vehicle trying to sneak
past us welcome anyways there's paint a
space to go around us but you know
perhaps they desperately wanted to be on
safari laughs who could blame them
anyways there's the prey species on the
other side of the river in the reserve
just grazing I suppose a zebra normally
do throughout their day now you can see
actually the front of the hood is not
going in the opposite direction that's
not good for us that's not what we want
turn around zebra and come back here
we've been sitting all day long yeah
that's an absolute lab we've not been
sitting all day long at this crossing
we've been sitting here for about 20
minutes and I'm growing impatient I
think you ought to come down to the
river it's so nice it's cool the waters
really refreshing you know it's you
could maybe dip your toes in the water
have a bit of a swim it mean it would be
risky because there's crocodiles and
things like that that you've already
shown you
lots of crocodiles but they're so full
don't worry there was a crossing here
yesterday perhaps they snatched right up
they're probably full
so we're not sure what's going to happen
we finally just gotta wait and see and
there's so many crossing points along
the nile river however there are also
many spots that we cannot get you but
main crossing is one of the popular
spots but whether they'll decide to well
suppose takes a plunge into the murder
of small river practice for TV we're
going to wait to find out hopefully this
afternoon remember this is a live and
interact or show you all being
exceptionally quiet today
hashtag safari live peace with your
questions or you can also talk to us on
the YouTube chat that would be very nice
thank you very much see you know I don't
think that there's a particular amount
of time that a crocodile will spend in
the Sun I think I think it's suppose
it's a day to day however I would say at
least forty percent of their day is
spent art basking in the Sun but all
those really cold overcast days you
actually don't see many crocodiles at
all you know they're probably just in
the water because you don't see them out
on the banks at all and but there's this
group over here there's the two massive
Crocs that we are looking at they're
exceptionally big you know they're well
over four meters in length is a couple a
little bit further downstream to which
we can't see which also maybe might even
be a bit bigger than this and so on a
nice warm day like this they'll recharge
his batteries it's perfect
they're in a good spot because if any
zebra do come down on either side of
them you know that it's quite easy for
them to just up in the water and then of
course try and eat them but again like I
said we yesterday we had a crossing here
and like one crocodile dived into the
water and tried to swim after the zebra
but it really was a half-hearted attempt
so there must just be full they don't
have to eat very much you know that with
crocodiles I mean they can go for many
months and up to a year without even
eating but I don't think that they go
that long sorry I'm not trapped myself
on the sorry aren't you I'm not stuck
like this I won't be able to me but
there's some hippos yeah so the so the
trucks I don't think necessarily eats or
you know don't go without food for about
a year they eat catfish and things in
between and lots of catfish in here now
that's part of hippos we see almost
every single day we can bast you
and they only woke up from their slumber
about ten minutes ago they were all out
on the banks of the river and now
they've decided to well cool themselves
off and they like it over there near the
rapids and sometimes we see those hippos
actually going towards the rapids and I
think must be like a massage
all that fuss flow and water going over
their backs and here's another small
group here Papapa thomas's these are the
Mara River dolphins which are cheer
night and I'll call them blue reds
no one is allowed to cross the river
here this is a no crossing zone so no
cars will enter the river although I'm
sure over the years someone's probably
trying to do it so there's designated
points so in order to cross the river to
get into the Maasai Mara you have two
options you can either go all the way
around outside of all or gates and then
it gets to Mercy arrogate which is in
the Maasai Mara National Reserve or you
can go all the way down to the south to
the border of Tanzania where there's a
bridge called the pouring gate bridge
all to Myra Bridge which is also known
as and you can cross down there and then
go into the Maasai Mara so those are the
ways that you can essentially cross the
river bridge down that side although I
did hear little governors I think
they've got like a pontoon don't they
hey Archie they pull do they pull
vehicles across which is exciting but I
don't really know how that works so I'm
not going to try and dive into too much
about that because unfortunately I just
I just don't know but it's not looking
very promising for us just yet I don't
think these ever unnecessarily gonna
cross this afternoon they could just
hang around and maybe you know we'll
meet them tomorrow morning at cul-de-sac
crossing and I've told you many times
that is my absolute favorite spot and
the reason why is because the water is
quite deep and there's also about three
and a half million crocodile they're not
really three and a half million but I
feel like a bulk of crocodiles and we
don't often get to see so many in in a
group together so it will keep that well
we'll keep that at the back of our minds
that might be where this herd goes but
we'll
would be move on from here I'll probably
go see if we can find some lions or
something along those lines
anyways off you go back to James who is
on a bit of a bumble yes I'm on a bumble
I'm looking for leopards that's what I
do there's a folktale trongo David you
see it it's that black bird it's flying
away quickly it's flying away hurry up
ah you got it
well done folktale to drum though one of
two drongo species we get here the other
the square tail drongo which I've never
seen here but apparently it does occur
I'm not convinced myself and it looks
exactly like that one except David it
has a square watch yes a square tail
well done absolute genius and now Emma's
just telling us that we are looking at a
folktale drongo which is very exciting
and that we haven't seen yes you
remember that thing you used to do when
you clicked
you remember that David what are you
supposed to do everybody when he brings
a camera back towards me go and then I'm
not like this looking at my monitor when
you come back to me and then I am see
watch watch this is how it's supposed to
look everybody watch this
okay go Dave see that's what it's
supposed to look like unfortunately
isn't it get to pick twice today sunday
is no click day apparently
right well this is very exciting in the
middle of the day that respond something
that's also listen a matriarchal society
but isn't an elephant can you guess what
it is yes indeed James very odd actually
to find a hyena
sitting in the middle of the day exactly
where we are in the Milwaukee this is
probably one of the first times I've
actually found hyenas here when there's
been no killer on so I'm actually just
scanning all the trees around me just in
case there is a sneaky leopard carcass
well not a leopard caucus but a carcass
that may be a lipid has caught and put
in a tree that is around here somewhere
but you can see the sauna is looking
rather dopey and happy with life
sleeping in in the middle of the sand
and it's suppose it's a great place to
have a bit of a rest yes I'm sorry am I
talking too loud I'll keep it down I do
apologize but it is a good place to race
because well the sand molds through
their body well so it's got a nice
little Bank with some shade that's going
to be the perfect place just to race for
the day stay nice and cool little bit of
a breeze that's funneling through the
drainage line it suppose fairly quiet as
well so it's a good place to be if you
are an animal it's why we often find
lion and leopard sleeping in the wall
our tea system during the course of the
day and many animals actually will sleep
on the sand you find even things like
Buffalo and any years will often come
and erased in these kind of areas now
I'm keeping my voice down because this
hyena gave me a glaring look I mean I
was speaking too loud so now I feel bad
and don't want to wake it up too much
but did you see how it got comfortable
and stuck its legs out the back so I
love when hyenas lie like that they all
push their back legs way arts and they
almost lie flat like we would with the
legs tucked under they chased just to
have a little bit of a rest and Lana yes
it is very normal for Ines to be on
their own like this it might be others
tucked up in the bush somewhere close by
but it is very very normal now Aubry is
calling me on the radio let me just
quickly get a hold of him go ahead Aubry
so normally you'll find hyenas on their
own like this when they looking around
for food and
so I'm just listening to all these
update quickly I'll get back into the
unis now so you're still talking and
there's a good update that we getting
I can't copy that observe so let me make
my way that side so it's just an update
on ting Ghana which is always very nice
but talking about hyenas on their own so
what you'll find with hyenas is that I
mean they do spend a lot of time by
themselves particularly if it's males
that are around they'll kind of move off
and do their thing and they go looking
for food and then because males don't
spend much time in a den site they'll
wander around and if they don't
reconnect with some of the other members
and they just find a spot to race during
the course of the day and you'll find
them on their own like this so it's
nothing and toured to see a hyena on its
own and normally you know we obviously
find them in groupings and that's
because when we do find them a lot of
the time it's when there's some sort of
kill around or some sort of ruckus
that's taken place that's attracting
more than one individual but it's very
common to find one walking around by
itself or lying down like this now I'm
pretty sure this is one of the clan
males difficult to see nicely I mean
it's obviously got its head tucked down
and even the tell-tale ilmar ear marks
are not really easy to see particularly
cuz the left is kind of folded away so
in terms of idea this one will be quite
tough I know that many of you are very
good at I doing our hyenas and often let
us know exactly who they are so Michael
and Chris rogue and all of you if you're
watching Krystal as well if you're
watching then you can maybe let us know
who exactly this is I am trying to learn
them so Michael has been very good at it
and has sent me a few ID kits for the
ena so I'm trying to get better at the
juma can particularly because they've
made a reappearance after a few months
of really not much going on we kind of
had no hyenas over the last few months
and then all of a sudden we've just got
this pushback in Koki and pretty and
have arrived back in this area and
they've really started to kind of settle
down and I know Steve had one of them
was it was this morning or maybe
yesterday that looks like she's very
full and lactating and I'm pretty sure
it must be cocky or pretty one of the
two of them and so it'll be interesting
to know where they're hanging around
what's noticeable is that the milliwatts
system seems to be the kind of core of
where we seeing them
he's seeing them east and west of the
system but a lot up and down and when
you come in the mornings lots and lots
of tracks buying is going all over the
place and so I wonder if they're just
trying to find a dinner I'm not sure if
they've actually given birth I kind of
doubt myself at the moment because we've
checked all the irregular spots we can't
really pinpoint a den and B given that
we are doing a lot of drone work in the
early mornings at the moment so we often
arts every single morning flying the
drone at night and we're not picking up
anywhere we're hyenas are sickening
every single morning so to me that
indicates either they haven't had yet or
- they've had it just off of our
boundary and they're using this as an
area - you hantum find food whereas and
then go back to dim off of Jummah or
they've waiting to your birth and they
just still trying to find up an
appropriate den site but given how much
they've been on Juma I'd be very very
surprised because if their den was off
of Jimin you would find that they would
go south or west or east a little bit to
go and forage for food as opposed to
just coming all the time to the north or
to whoever they you know - due to Juma
itself so I have a funny feeling that
there might be somewhere and just
looking around for something so John
Michael definitely a size of an ear is
is often indicative of how good their
hearing is you can imagine when you've
got a tiny tiny small ear the amount of
sound waves they can grow in there's
probably far reduced relative to the
size of the eardrum and to give you an
idea of how much it can affect your
hearing when you're sitting at home now
John Michael take your hand and make it
into a sort of C shape so almost do it
like this so just make that kind of
shape with your hand I'm gonna do it on
my left here because I didn't earpiece
in my RIT as it does really work and
then you just cup it around your ear
like this and just have a listen as to
how much better you actually hear so
anything where you've got a little bit
bigger that can trap more sound and
funnel it into the eardrum will help you
to hear things a little bit better so
it's often why people do this when
they're trying to listen to something
and trying to hear something so it's
it's it does help them and you'll find a
lot of the nocturnal creatures tend to
have quite big ears in relation to the
size of their heads and so things like
hyenas and your fine line and lipids
their ears are quite big
even you know there's all kinds of
nocturnal animals like Jen it's of its
so it's not so much funnily enough but
Jen it's definitely the ears are quite
big and perky you'll find things like
the nocturnal mice gerbils their ears in
relation to the size of their body all
quite large and are able to kind of pick
up a lot of sound I'm sorry are we
keeping you awake nope just really get
getting comfortable now it's getting
into that perfect tight you know pose
where legs are stretched in all
directions while its head goes down
right so well ah is still very much
sleepy we're going to head off now on
try and see if we can go catch up with
ting gana while we do that that send you
back across to Brent
Leo Smith who's up in the Mara I wonder
if he's got his goggles on as he gazes
upon the Lions that are still dozing off
ever so sorry
absolutely zero updates from the sausage
tree pride they are still lying in the
exact same position as there were
earlier and I don't foresee them doing
too much just yet it's still quite warm
and the smorgasbord of prayer that was
around them this morning he's a little
bit far off we've got some zebras some
topi some gazelles
biade move in the distance
I'm just trying to see you know it's I
think it's a bit too far for you to hear
but right in the distance you can hear
the wildebeest mooing mooing yeah you
can see some bull beast in the distance
there hello Scott
mr. Koch is wondering do lions kill
leopards if they get the opportunity yes
there will all apex predators given the
opportunity will try remove another
predator from the ecosystem leopards
will often kill little lion cubs if they
get the chance so will hyenas and
vice-versa
now of course lions are much much bigger
than a leopard a very big male leopard
will weigh around 90 kilograms 200 or so
pounds there is a very small male line
weigh 180 190 kilograms almost double
the weight and a lioness 120 130
kilograms for a big one 115 220 there
are a lot bigger and a lot stronger than
a leopard and leopards obviously have a
little bit faster turn of speed for
escape but also they can climb trees
well if they get caught out here I'm far
away from a tree it might not be too
good to be a leopard being chased by
lions I have heard of leopards even
going down warthog holes to try escape
lions in this part of the world so the
instinct to survive is quite strong so
we'll see what happens
Colleen is wondering do lions eat water
back Colleen yes indeed they do it is a
complete old wives tale that they don't
eat water back because they don't like
the taste of water back because the
gland on the base of the neck that
secretes that oily substance if a lion
is hungry it will eat water back the
fact that it will not know what the the
story that it won't eat water back is a
complete and utter twaddle what you got
through the gap in the trees there
they've got small zebras I think
now we're looking all the way down to
Tanzania in the distance here we go so
that actually is my finger in here is it
no I'm not going to get my finger in
there sorry if um just go back there so
that far Ridge over there that is very
much Tanzania even the foreground but
there you can see there's a little
Valley in there and that's the Mara
River where it flows into Tanzania and
you see there's still some fire fires
burning on the southeastern side of the
Mara River inside the Serengeti National
Park and you can see we are sitting on
the big burn that happened in the Mara
triangle a few weeks ago and that lush
green grass is what's bringing all the
beasts zebra topi Tommy's here and
that's what's bringing the Lions as well
now that little info berg there is right
on the border and favorite hangout of
the border boys - male cheetah you know
quite often seen in that area
hi well and Willis's we haven't seen the
Thompson's gazelle in the wild are there
at the back of the migration yes the the
migrating Tommy's that is but we do have
quite a large resident or there's a dust
devil resident population of Tommy's
that actually never leave the Mara and
there are quite a few but they are very
far off I'm afraid dr. de monks the rule
of eastern zebra I can see some Tommy
Jerry and I struggle there and see those
are the closest Darian so if we go up to
that lone tall Bala nice that's got all
the vultures in it that one there yes
and we go off to the left slightly along
the ground somewhere there we go is that
an Impala what does Impala
no he keep going left from the Impala
and there was a little herd of Tommy's
there somewhere Oh what I think it might
be behind the bush for them oh yeah
sorry then the Tommy's
under Bush maybe we can find it Tommy
that's not and you see the wind has
started gusting again here in the Mara
Lynch send you back into James with a
birdie
sorry cut line he's north of the
boundary buddy they say he's like farm
ears up the road
well he went further north and is now
coming now unfortunately we had no comms
there at all so we are live now we're
just chatting - Craig exactly waiting
ganas and where we going to go he's
north of a boundary at the moment but
we'll try and see if we can pick him up
and see if we can get a view of him but
it's been I'm just sorry I was just
heard about a herd of elephants - where
is that no unbuckles hook not going to
help us at all for world elephant day so
we're gonna try and see if we can get
hit off towards dingo and I'm gonna go
up on vultures nests
just to check if there's any sign for
tani Colombo or sana
in the meantime I'm pretty sure Hassan
is gonna kill somewhere if he hasn't
shown up at any of the water points and
we've checked pretty much all of them
and he's either on a kill always crossed
out of our area for the first time in a
long time but given that we haven't seen
any tracks I highly doubt that that is
the case so I think he might be still
lurking about some way
it's a very breezy afternoon we checked
around that hyena as well no sign of any
tracks for Leopard no lipid kills in any
of the trees it's just the tracks fly
you know coming down the road and then
down the drainage line and lying down
there so so obviously just having a
little sleep and taking it very easy it
was very relaxed when we drove past it
just sat there looking at us as we went
past and then decided to have a little
bit of a rest and sleep once million so
still then if we don't have lack of
Tigana we can always go back now I'm
going to carry on northwards towards
Gauri cut line while I do that send you
back cross to James Henry who I believe
is well looking at something that's in
Ghana might want to eat
maybe very lucky to catch one of these
things it's a very large water buck bull
I rent of course was talking about the
fact that it is an old person's tale
that water buck are not eaten by lions
that is of course true what Brent says
not what the old people say that's very
unusual for that to be the case anyway
the other thing that is I think
something of a misconception regarding
water buck is that they always run into
water and when I was reading up on them
the other day and none of these
textbooks are infallible of course it
said nothing about that but it did say
that they're very water dependent and
that's why you'll find them in the
vicinity of water more often than not
and they have quite an interesting
territorial set up because of it
obviously there's a finite amount of
water and so what you'll find is that
water buck bulls will set up territories
close to water big fellows like this but
they will tolerate youngsters within
their territories and subordinate bulls
within their territories if they don't
cause trouble and interestingly also
apparently we're going to discuss this
later
let's go across Tristan who's got a
world something of the day on the move
well I'll any search has been rewarded
basically so we found one little young
bull Ellie that is by itself that is
walking around and so happy well
elephant day to everybody hopefully it
will be a sign of many illnesses
afternoon and it's such an important
thing that we have these kind of days
and I have shared a few pictures on my
own social media in it I have kind of
two feelings about these days that we
have one is that it is very important
that we raise awareness and that there
are days dedicated to such iconic
species like the elephants and two days
ago was also lions and that we have
these because it raises awareness and
tries to get more and more people to
know what is going on but a very large
part of me gets very sad that we do have
days like this one because the reason we
have these days is these animals are
being persecuted at a rate of knots and
we have really got a lot of issues
surrounding not only you know elephants
and lions but many of the iconic African
animals and it's really is sad to think
that many of these populations have been
absolutely decimated by the hands of
humans and the Cree that we show
sometimes when it comes to these animals
now he's just wandering off I'm not
going to follow him through here and
I'll tell you why one is that it is
incredibly windy and this animal already
shared its ears and was looking a little
kind of stressed about us being here and
when it's windy often Elly's will be a
little bit funny two years where it's
walking now is that is so thick in there
that all I'm going to do is hit trees
and speakers elephant even more what I
did notice is there is tracks for the
rest of the herd going in and I'm pretty
sure they're heading up towards the dam
so they're gonna go towards where the
dam cam is I think that's the route that
they're heading into the mawashi and
then hopefully northwards so I'm gonna
go round and then hopefully catch them
towards the dam a little bit late
this afternoon that's the plan at least
but I was saying that it's important
that we kind of talk about Elias and me
when any of the iconic animals and try
and raise more awareness and try and get
as many people to understand how dire a
lot of the situations are when it comes
to these animals you know we kind of
often see things and even as people who
work with in these areas and see animals
on a day to day basis we have become a
little complacent in that you know we
see them in populations of elephants
here where we are healthy and not being
persecuted nearly as much as maybe
populations elsewhere in the world and
it's it's an important reminder that's
you know we need to be more focused and
more kind of aware of what's going on
and try and sort these things out
because if we don't it's not going to be
a very long period and there will be
nothing left for anybody to view and can
you imagine what a sad day it would be
to drive around a place like this and
see absolutely no elephants no lions no
anything it would really be a very very
very depressing thing to do so I'm
hoping that in life we'll come up with a
plan and people will forget about how
greedy they are and start to actually
focus on looking after animals and
coexisting and hopefully then we'll be
able to start seeing these guys thrive
once again it's pretty dire when you
think that both elephants and lions have
been reduced to pretty much about 20% of
their original range
scenic it depends on what reserve you're
in but here in the sabi sands any's are
protected mostly by very very very
efficient anti poaching units so the
guys that are trying to stop rhino
poaching are the same ones that are
protecting these areas from elephant
poachers and making sure that they're
not getting into the reserves and
actually trying to hunt these elephants
it's it's not an easy job and we do lose
elephants and the Kruger went through a
very good period where we had almost
zero elephant poaching and it's just
starting to increase again right on the
fringes of the south african border with
Zimbabwe and Mozambique and so we're
gonna have to be a bit careful in the
interview just keep an eye out and try
and concentrate a little ardour and
trying to keep people art the problem
with a lot of the elephant poaching
that's happening at the moment is
because ivory is not consumed by people
it's is you know it's used for
decorative purposes and those kind of
things it doesn't need to be consumed so
they how they kill them is often by
poison at the moment and what they do is
they go to a waterhole and they'll
poison a water hole and viennese then
drink from it and as well as many other
animals so lions and vultures and
antelopes they usually use a substance
called timming which is very very bad
it's pesticide base to begin kills
everything and that's how they get these
areas and then they just come gonna get
in there are obviously times when they
do get speared and shots and all kinds
of other things in other parts of Africa
but in Kruger mostly what they've been
seeing is it's either a rifle or a
poisoning that happens not always
calling me again
go ahead orbs
Gary Kaplan in the central junction
tell me that thanks Forbes I'll be there
in two minutes
sir what were he's just checking where I
am because he wants to leave to Ghana
but he doesn't want to leave before we
get there in case we drive past him
which is very very nice it will be but
so our ranges of anti-poaching units
here are vitally important they really
do a lot to try and kind of protect our
knees as much as possible now sorry am i
hardly heard you all I heard is Maura so
I think I'm gonna be sending you off to
the morrow the wind is really playing
havoc with being able to hear anything
so afternoon but hopefully it is the
Mara and hopefully it is too something
exciting
well those lines have not moved a muscle
and there has been one change that we
have spotted a Thomson's gazelle much
closer you see him there is a couple
wandering around just over there mm-hmm
yeah they are for those who wanting to
see Tommy's who've missed them
now let's hope she it is a female there
and she moves out I find Tommy's
absolutely fascinating there are an
antelope species where the females are
in the process of evolving to not have
any horns so Impala female kudu female
Bush but FEMA and Nala have already gone
through this process and you often find
really but he scrappy bits of horn on
female Thompson's gazelles the male
still have really prominent very visible
horns but the females often bent askew
all sorts of funny shapes and angles on
them because the evolution process is
still taking place other than that we
had did have a little look like a black
fly catcher that popped in to visit but
it's disappeared its flitting around in
this little croton thicket around here
we go I can't see it at the moment
monique is wondering what is the
difference between a Thompson's gazelle
and a spring buck well firstly one that
lives in the arid desert areas of
southern Africa over probably 2,000
kilometers or a little bit less than
that well over 2,000 kilometres away
from the closest Thomson's gazelle which
are endemic to East Africa that Tommy's
there and they're probably the closest
relative to a gazelle in southern Africa
is a springbok and you can see they have
very similar colorations and whatnot
Tommy's are quite a bit taller they
horns are a lot more prominent as well
and if a springbok had to live in an
area as wet as the Mara once that
smoting going on down there
it's just something you see the zebras
having roll in the dust they of him now
if a springbok had to live in an area as
wet as the Mara they would actually get
foot rot people have tried to move
Springbok into wetter areas in southern
Africa be nice to have a springbok on my
farm type thing and there have died out
quite quickly due to foot rot so there
are desert adapted creatures they're not
going to like the the west of the Mara
first the end you probably find that the
Thompson's gazelles wouldn't like the
dry of the Kalahari now grants gazelles
a little bit more adaptable there they
do occur into much drier areas in the
Masai step which is that way so beyond
yet was adversity and stuff you go down
and gets drier and dry as you get
towards the coastal plain you get by saw
Oryx their golden wolf who knew there
were two species of wolf in Africa so up
until very recently the the golden
jackal which is now in an Asiatic
species only was considered to live in
the more drier areas along the east
eastern dry land Sava down into the
Masai step into into into Tanzania and
Serengeti just on the edge but now with
genetics and stuff it's turned out that
they are not they're actually a real
expression of gray wolf that have
reduced water VM ah a topi that have
been isolated in Africa they're much
much smaller I will see if I can
actually find your picture of them so
I've been keeping a careful look out and
all the black back jackal and the Mara
because you never know there could be a
a small population of African golden
wolves
it's amazing how much stuff you can
actually see from a p.m. KB is wondering
what is the advantage of female antelope
having forum horns it would be for
defensive predators and when you as
small as a Thomson's gazelle be there's
pretty much nothing you can do now with
the males obviously they have the horns
for sexual competition for fighting over
mating rights where there's the females
have slowly not slowly progressed and
evolved not to have those prominent
horns anymore
if you think about there's actually very
few female species of antelope that have
horns the most notable one that we
actually see and I did I see some a
little bit earlier in the distance that
we see in the Mara
he's eland and this is probably one of
the first days where I haven't been able
to see it Elin in this area they might
have gone for a drink I'm checking it on
that little waterhole there NIDA
no ways they must be an eland and I'm
just being blind
no I cannot see a single Eiland amongst
everything else
well I'm gonna keep looking for a
picture of that African golden wolf for
you in the meantime let's send you
across to Tristan he's got a lovely
Sunday afternoon surprise we do indeed
we've got a rather sleepy Duke that has
decided to take a nap right next to the
side of the main road so he's having a
really good kind of serious sleep and
I'm Khan blaming me walked quite far
this morning from where Steve found him
to where he is now
he's a good good distance and you can
see he's got quite a full belly so I'm
not surprised that the Duke has passed
out and decided this is where he is
going to nap and where he's going to
take it very easy he's just on the
northern side of our boundary on purfles
oxide but close enough that we can get a
perfect view of him should he even wake
up he's I think going to nap there
pretty successfully much like our hyena
was it for the majority of this
afternoon wait for that Sun to get down
a little bit and then it'll be
interesting to see which way he goes
because he's kind of been pushing into
buffers look a lot more of late been a
lot of vocalizing and then he heads
quite far north the guys were telling me
the other day that he wins at least a
kilometer north in before sook which is
a long long way it's much further than
he's been in a long time so I wonder if
there's maybe not a female that's in
Easter us up here or something that's
going on or he's just stamping his his
mark because he's tired of having all
these other young males roaming around
in all these sections and kind of
pushing into his area given that he is
the dominant individual you would expect
him to come back after being a bit sick
and to really try and stamp his
authority and he's been successful in
putting haka Murray further west and
keeping him at bay for now and so now
he's got to deal with the likes of oak
Ozzy and quite till a not quite in a
female that we know but quite Tilly the
male that came out of that Steve once so
I think was Steve yet Steve saw Dom near
treehouse damn so that just random young
male that hunted a warthog I don't know
if any of you remember that but Katella
has been seen a lot actually around the
gates and has been seen on some abuse
islet one IPAN so I'm pretty sure he's
been on Zoomer
quite frequently we just have missed him
probably because we actually hadn't been
spending a lot of time in the northwest
of the property so he's been around and
then there's also a couple of other
random males and so I'm pretty short in
Ghana is kind of growing up and just
trying to really sort things out and
just make sure that everybody
understands that he's back and Israeli
the ruler of this area now it's been
amazing to watch his resurgence from
this sort of meek figure that looked
down and out and looked down trodden to
this you know supremely confident male
once again he was vocalizing in scent
marking and looking bulky and good again
it's been actually wonderful to watch
and just goes to show you how resilient
these big cats can be you know if you're
it's kind of given was said this is what
would have unfolded many people would
have said it was not going to happen so
sorry I'm if you can just repeat that
again for me yes I mean it's to be able
to say yeah you know they're both cats
that kind of don't have a lot of
endurance when it comes to running for
long periods of time so you know lipids
and lions are actually pretty similar in
a lot of respects they both built very
similar and powerful big cats that are
not designed to run marathons I probably
say in terms of endurance to run for a
longer period at top speed I would say
Lions given that Lions hunt in a certain
way they like to kind of go and hunt in
more open sections and we said in the
Mara that they probably end up chasing
for a lot further than a leopard does
and if it is an ambush predator and in
these kind of areas we'll generally only
use a short burst of speed and then stop
so I would imagine Lions have a high
endurance in terms of top-end speed and
running for longer in terms of walking
and just going around all day long
difficult to say both of them are pretty
good at doing it we see you know male
lions and male if it's covering huge
distances in some areas so in terms of
walking they probably very very similar
in fact I don't think they'd be too much
difference between them but top-end
speed and running I would imagine that
Lions do run for longer stints when they
have that top-end speed then what lipids
do lip is tend to be much sure
distance animals and so because of the
way that they hunt it's a very different
way of hunting compared to what Lions do
they aren't going to be using these long
winded chases through open grassland to
bring down their preys a little bit
shorter running times although it's
saying that I once had the most epic
hunt from a mullah Chatwin at the
airstrip so it just makes the haste
replace that big open clearing and
watched Lula run like a cheetah across
the end Killaloe in parlor it was pretty
impressive stuff he must have run easily
over I would say probably about 200
meters actually and the impalas for some
reason just bombs shelled in all
directions and one ran straight at him
and he was able to just kind of slam it
to the ground so they do have these kind
of things where they are able to run off
to impalas and those and and and
sometimes make a hunt like that but very
seldom and so the endurance at top speed
is quite slow
well quite short should I say now indeed
it was an epic sighting it was an
amazing thing to watch as quite
surprised by it all actually it was
complete pandemonium and you'll see you
just saw you know we had a flat tire and
in this villa as we got the flat tire we
were out to try and change it cousin
bulla was walking and hunting and we
were kind of changing it to me just saw
him start to go and jump back in the car
with the flat tire lifts the spare tire
lying on the ground drove on the flat
tire to try keep up with him and then
saw him take it down was just absolute
pandemonium and chaos chaos so you know
it was a quite an epic sighting but it
was one that didn't last very long after
that because unfortunately hyenas
arrived and stole the kill from a ruler
but amazing to watch now David you think
the rainy season is going to bring
hooker money back possibly and it
depends it depends on what goes on her
camera is going very very very far waste
at the moment he's been seen going into
Ottawa which is the western side of
elephant Plains so towards singita which
is a long way I can tell you that from
where we are and so it's very possible
that hukum area unless he finds a female
in heat so Tandy could be the kind of
key to all of this if it missed and he
drags him back yeah I don't know if
we're gonna see too much of him he's now
mating with the likes of Tianyi and
should do Lu and if he has Cubs that
side I wouldn't be surprised if he
spends more time there trying to protect
those Cubs and trying to protect that
area because he's been mating then it is
to come all the way east like this so
maybe the rainy season does bring him
back into this area I think it's there's
a lot of variables that might are at
play and it's not only the rainy season
but it's 10 Ghana's health and fitness
over the next few months and yes rainy
season will be much harder on ting Ghana
it's gonna be much harder to hunt you
know it's the cats the big cats really
struggle a little bit in the rainy
season compared to the winter the winter
makes it much easier for them they coats
blend in better as well as you know
animals being distributed in areas where
they can regularly find them in with
summer everybody's spread out and
becomes a little harder for these guys
to find food regularly so that's that's
two factors the third is what happens
with husana what is husana end up doing
and whether asana challengers in Ghana
or challenges for Komori in some way at
some point because he will at some point
once he starts getting to this time next
year
Hassan is going to be pushing to start
having a territory you know by then he's
three years old and that's when you
often see males starting to move and
become nomadic and before they're
starting to really challenge so Hassan
is gonna be an interesting part of this
whole component and what other lipids
arrive in the meantime you know if we
think back a year ago
there was no such thing as hooker Murray
Feiss a year ago and nor was there for
Carswell because he would just started
to arrive quite tila male was we didn't
know about him we didn't know about a
lot of these males that have been seen
on Buffalo's hook there's another
unknown male that keeps being seen as
well around the northern Baja so purfles
hook so you know there's a lot of
variables at play and those will all
depict what happens it also depends on
what happens with Anderson what happens
on the western side of Herkimer he does
a male lipid come in there and chase him
back east or does he find more females
to the west and and become more dominant
westwards
it's it's an interesting thing in the
last few years what we've seen he's most
of the males dispersed eastwards as they
get older so if you look at Smurf
opinion he was dominant around the
central parts of our souza and then he
started to slowly push more and more
east until eventually we've seen a lot
around chitra then you had him Fulop he
was mostly in the East in Ghana was the
same he came from elephant Plains from
any area pushed his way west now
dominant on this eastern side
and so we'll see what happens you know
the before those though there was a
lineage with Tyson and that lot that war
winds Southwest and so I wonder if
Herkimer is going to be one of those
that pushes to the southwest rather then
back this way who knows it's gonna be
interesting but it'll definitely the
rain season will shake things up again
it's a whole different set of problems
that these animals will face and and you
know if Tenggara can't find food
regularly then who knows his condition
could plummet again quite quickly and
and you'll find that he you know could
then be asked it laura angular's
disappearance and we've discussed this
many many times and there's no real new
update on it unfortunately it's one of
those things that happens young lipids
do disappear from time to time it's not
ideal but it does happen
chunky lay I mean she she was only a
year old really was just over a year old
when she met Tandy which is makes life
very difficult for her she's you know
was never going to be physically matched
to Tandy Tandy was bigger stronger wiser
you know there's a lot more to to more
of a point to prove in what chunky
leaded so you know she was always gonna
struggle whether or not that means that
she got fatally injured that day we
don't know and we have absolutely zero
idea what happened after the Tandy fight
which was on the 16th of August if I'm
not mistaken so four days from now a
year ago is when that all happened and
where she ended up what actually
happened we have really no idea the next
morning Taylor went there she saw a lot
of tracks going in a lot of different
directions so with it right there I
think we would have found a carcass at
that actual kill site or some sort of
evidence that she had died there i if
she did die from that interaction it was
because she probably got very badly
injured and wandered off and eventually
then died somewhere else or she she
pushed into another area and
unfortunately ran into some other lipids
or liens or something that that maybe
killed her or she's well she's still
alive when she's walking around in some
random block in the middle of Kruger
that no one sees her and no one even
knows where she is it happens I mean we
know that's
Siobhan B'Elanna Mishu and Oona even
sacani who's really done very well so
for those of you who don't know who any
of those lipids are a lot of those are
equivalents or other offspring that were
boys that went into Kruger and we get
very rare updates on them in fact
sometimes it goes months before we see
any sighting of them and sacani was a
female that came from Cortile which is a
similar line to tequila-soaked ULA's
mother was Safari Safari had in team and
team hours or so and was the mother of
Katella so it's the same kind of lineage
roughly and but not this exact same
mother and she ended up going all the
way down into the Kruger Park area and
she's now dominant south of skukuza long
long long way away from where we are
she's had a first litter of Cubs which
is very exciting and they are being seen
quite a bit and you know you would never
have thought well I never would have
thought it and all my experience I've
never seen a female travel that far and
so it's you cannot rule out the
possibility that chunky layers ended up
going deep into the grooviest somewhere
into an area where no cars are going and
we just don't have updates on her it's
it's very possible let's remember that
some blocks inside Kruger are three
times the size without a road there's
not one single road going through them
or three times the size of the entire
sabi sands so when you think about that
think about how many leopards are
dominant in the sabi sands female Y's
are pretty sure it's close to about 50
and then you think of an area three
times the size of that and that's where
she could have gone into so it could be
in an area where there's a hundred and
fifty or hundred different lipids that
are dominant in that section and she
could just be right in the middle of all
of that so it's possible that she's
still alive possible that she's just
hiding out in one of those blocks and
the only thing for me is that to get to
that point I would have thought somebody
would have seen her she was a relaxed
lipid she was a lipid that was easily
visible
she didn't wasn't shy from vehicles and
I would have thought we would have got
one kind of update some way of her
getting out of the section heading into
the Kruger but we didn't and you know
it's possible she did so I don't know I
mean I for me I strongly believe that
she unfortunately something happened to
I don't think we would have seen her
just vacation not come back once more I
mean we've seen with asana how he's
stuck around even though he's interacted
with many different lipids sure he
hasn't had the same violent interaction
but he was there that day he was part of
that whole process and it didn't faze
him in the least he was still around so
I wonder if something else didn't happen
to and she just try to move off and
bumped into something else or you never
know I mean they could have been all
kinds of things that could have played
out that day many other lipids were
around and she managed to charm willow
that I me at the times that she bumped
into him but could have been very
different if she'd bumped into another
male lipid that was in puffles hook or
something like that so it's a sad thing
to think about she really was an
unbelievable leopard is by far the most
relaxed lipid that I think I've ever
seen on foot I've never seen a leopard
behave that she did on foot it was
really quite phenomenal to watch her and
watch some of the interactions at James
and Brent and Jamie and pretty much
everybody had with her in you know in
the beginning of last year it was just
incredible incredible scenes watching
her go about her business and see how
she ended up doing things so it is a big
loss and hopefully one day she'll make
an appearance somewhere that would be
quite nice good well while we sit with
Singhania whose belly up and sleeping
away the day let's send you back all the
way across to Brent Leigh as Smith who I
think is probably in a similar boat to
us in his watching his Alliance sleep
and I wonder what he thinks about Jean
Keeler's disappearance now our constant
companion for the day the bustling Masai
Mara wind is back of course soon as we
tried to frame up on the bedraggled
Croton bush it stopped a little bit bye
dad I have to go take a photograph of
the golden jackal at some point because
our golden wolf sorry golden jackal are
in Asia so that is the African golden
wolf now of all the canid species that
are alive today the large canid species
I wonder if you can tell me I'm gonna
give you a list of a couple
and you've got to tell me which is the
most ancient okay which of these is the
most ancient the dog the European gray
wolf for American gray wolf air the same
the Himalayan gray wolf which is the
Asiatic wolf version of the wolf what
other one can we throw in there African
wild dog coyote or side striped jackal I
think of anymore I can throw the old
black bat jackal just for fun Oh Asiatic
golden jackal which of those is the most
ancient means it's been split from the
main line it's got the most ancient
genetic line hashtag Safari live if you
think you know the answer and no
cheating with Google someone will be
watching not me of course cuz I'm
watching a bush but under the bushes a
line that has not moved in how many
hours of in survived 11 this morning
oh good few hours so what's that I don't
even know what time is now seven hours
well so that since that that those lions
have moved they walk quite a long
distance after feasting on a few of all
the beasts this morning but they didn't
finish those will be so we're hoping
they're still angry and we're hoping
that some idiotic canoe is going to come
stumbling into them or zebra
can just bless and listen to the wind
there for a bit
remember this is live we can't force
these animals to get up and on the move
on their schedule so we will be waiting
for the lions on the lion's share job
that's what doing live wild life is all
about
let's go see how my good friend James
Henry is doing well we found something
that's standing up at least it's not a
cat it's not what we were looking for
but there we have some kudu okay you do
you Q do female q dues FM fe ma le GU
dues I'm not sure where that came from
I'm sorry for that everybody I was
obviously taken by the spirit of some
long dead thespian there we have a
female kudu and she's got three friends
four friends that is not unusual
not because Koo dues are necessarily
more friendly than anyone else but
because they choose to live in small
groups which helps them to see predators
that might want to eat them and in this
particular area I think they're pretty
safe I've seen very few could who's
being eaten I know the Minka Puma pride
did kill a male to male Cruz I think
recently but the females tend to be able
to stay away from them for some reason
they're a great meal for a lion
they're not exactly bristling with
weaponry to fend off lion attack they
are fast they can kick and they can jump
and I suspect maybe Lions just think
that there are easier things to get at
but I would have thought that quite easy
to kill because they live in thick bush
like normally to find them in the open
like this is quite unusual so who knows
maybe they don't taste so good Omkara
the first fastest herbivore that we have
is Steve Falconbridge he is a herbivore
he's the only herbivore we have the runs
so he is the fastest that we have I am
of course being facetious he's not
faster than a Thomson's gazelle the
fastest antelope in the world contrary
to what we told you for months last year
he's not the topi it is the Thomson's
gazelle the Thomson's gazelle is almost
as fast as a cheetah but not quite it
can run at about 90 km/h they think it's
very difficult to measure of course
because if you ask a Thomson's gazelle
to run in a straight line they normally
stare at years there you've stepped out
of a piece of cheese there's not
surprising there English and Swahili is
not quite what it should be so it's very
difficult to work out exactly how fast
they are they can work it out with
cheetah because cheetah have been
domesticated in some places and there's
that amazing film of them shooting a
cheetah at full stretch basically they
make it run like a mad greyhounds run
they put a a rabbit on a winch you're
not a real rabbit everybody it's a fake
bunny on a winch and the cheetah chases
it in a straight line so they can
measure exactly how fast it's going and
they shoot it with a very specialized
camera that shoots at over a thousand
frames per second and you don't really
need to know what that means but it's
just super slow-mo and it is astounding
to watch the cheetah move at that speed
anyway that's not got a huge amount of
relevance to what you're looking at
there other than to say
Omkar we do know that the Thomson's
gazelle is extremely fast much faster
than the kudu but the kudu holds another
Olympic record and that is for high jump
they are able to jump very high
I think that would be the fastest
herbivore in the world very gorgeous and
there's one actually chewing its cud
lying down there you see that David
underneath the dead tree that we've used
on bush walk 587 times yeah it is
chewing her cud yes it is a lovely
Sunday view a lot of you saying you're
enjoying the Sunday view I like to walk
normally on Sunday afternoons I find
that the most appropriate thing to do
unfortunately the bush walk camera is
well shall we say in a state of
disrepair at the moment and so to walk
is not possible so I've had to bring the
car out on Sunday afternoon but that's
okay we're having a peaceful kudu
sighting it is of course world elephant
day which I must mention even though I
can't find any elephants just yet I will
keep trying to find some elephants is
there a world kuru day there probably
isn't sorry chaps no world could a day
you just make every day you'll see world
could a day I guarantee if there was a
world could a day we wouldn't find one
on this property so one two three four I
think they're actually six of them it's
excusable the one on the left is being
particularly an inspirational I feel at
this stage it's not really doing a great
deal it's not dancing it's not jumping
running
no kudos call horns in this particular
case their total growth length will be
not centimeters because of course
they're all females but look the males
have horns you know and I don't know
what the longest would be I'm gonna
guess probably about I reckon about four
feet you know I reckon the longest horns
would be around about four feet long
which is 13 meters no that's wrong it's
the other way around isn't it it's just
every meet it's about one and a half
meters tall so that's quite a lot
doesn't sound right does it one and a
half meters now one point one point
three meters also um 13 meters is
definitely wrong a 13 meter kudu horn
would be something to see I suspect the
could who wouldn't be able to lift its
head
ah well we've now got a hold a search
team going in the final control
apparently 6 feet the longest could hoo
hoo neveress really d ever recorded
that's about one point seven eight
meters so that's huge that's actually
massive that's a little taller than me
David I know that's difficult to believe
it's in fact your height you're six feet
are you not yes you are I am NOT I am
three foot four
all right I believe that the great quiz
master is back in action it's quite nice
to have the great quiz master back in
action let's go back across to him find
out what you've won with all of your
answers to his great quiz three two one
well since the Lions are near-invisible
the quiz game will continue now I asked
you which was the most ancient of course
when I mean they diverged from the same
line so we'll see who got it right who
got it wrong and he was completely on
the wrong side of the world so far we
are not having luck with any idiotic
wildly beasts blundering in as they do
do from time to time them and I were
just chatting and working out how long
we've been with these lions today and we
found them just the fall probably oh I
caught it to 6:00 this morning
so in a little while we would have been
with them for 12 hours consecutively
well back to the quiz Jared's buddy said
the American gray wolf Bab not correct
at least said the gold Asiatic golden
jackal also not correct so I'll give you
a little bit of time see if anyone else
has got any answers I'm sure someone
must get it right names in this wind
which is now back in full force
refa said African wild dog no but I
think our own davies was correct and and
that was it is indeed the side striped
and black-backed jackal that's separated
from from the main Canaan a line so dog
is the most recent but here we go at the
side striped and black back jack -
six million years ago and African wild
dog around 1.9 million years ago the
golden Asiatic called jackal between one
point nine one point six million years
or actually one point six billion years
Ethiopian wolf one point three million
years and we got coyote Himalayan wolf
eight hundred thousand one point 1
million eight hundred thousand years and
the dog and the American will holarctic
which is the correct term gray wolf
which occurs into Europe Russia North
America is actually relatively recent
within the last five hundred thousand
years so there we got a little bit of
Canada Canada I love what I had canid
history maybe guy took it a while to get
out and it's definitely taking the
sausages a while to get out of their
lovely little spot this evening so I'm
hoping this strong wind doesn't lead to
good hunting weather let's hope
hopefully they didn't eat too much today
and they're not going to want to leave
it the seclusion one of the reasons they
moved into this area where we were where
we are now we were over there in the
distance you can see those here we go we
were a little bit to the right of him
those trees in the distance were
somewhere over there now the amount of
dust that's coming off there the ground
and the short grass and the burnt areas
and dust devils and from the burn was
causing a lot of discomfort not only for
our eyes but also for the Lions eyes
that's why I think they're moved on to
this little isolated pocket yeah that
didn't get burnt it was quite green when
the fire came through and also has these
little Croton bushes for shade
almost just to get away from that
incessant wind and sand now someone
who's not dealing with incessant wind
and sand is tan gana whose chest having
a lazy Sunday afternoon
indeed Kangana is having a very lazy
Sunday afternoon which is fun that's
okay he needs to save up all his
strength so that he can keep roaming
around in keeping one hasanah around and
to allowing her number to grow up nice
and strong so I'm quite happy with him
to be around and to be sleeping so he
conserves his energy for his nocturnal
sort of joints that he does and you can
see he's kind of flattened himself out a
little bit when we lost so I mean it was
on his back of it so his paws upwards
now flattened himself out and his belly
is moving quite briskly and a lot of
people often see cats and see them
breathing like this and things that
there's a problem and but no that's not
how any anything to worry about that's
pretty normal for cats particularly ones
with full bellies they do breathe quite
rapidly and that's just part of the
controlling body temperature as well as
the the fullness of their Bailey pushing
up on their lungs decreasing their
capacity to take in huge amounts of
oxygen so slightly quicker breath when
they have eaten a lot I wonder from like
I was saying earlier I wonder from here
where he's going to go one of two
directions the thing is with the wind is
that it's pushing a little bit from the
north so I'd imagine he's going to walk
into the wind and I don't think that we
would see him walking southwards with
the wind at his back I'm pretty sure
he's gonna push her further north deep
into puffles look interesting enough
while I've been sitting here one of the
guys told me that the in Kakuma pride
eventually this morning went into the
north and managed to kill a buffalo and
they apparently are in this right on the
money laity
boundary with Buffalo on the money laity
side but they are sharing the cart
whirling around the carcass with the
telematic right so no wonder there is so
much noise emanating from the north this
morning it's because those two prides
are very close together and apparently
their vocal boys are somewhere in the
mix there too so it's all chaos up that
size and and I wonder if we're gonna see
any fallout from that and whether or not
they'll share it amicably or if they're
going to move interesting enough I was
talking to Rick's about the income apart
and I know he's looking at ting on and
straying off on a major tangent at the
moment but I was talking to Rex and he
was telling me that the telemetry's
Torchwood's
and in comas originally all stemmed from
the same pride now I'm not sure if
that's a hundred percent right maybe
somebody will be able to tell me this
but he's of the belief that they do and
that's why that they've seen many
sightings of Nkrumah's telemetry's and
cool mist orchards actually sharing
kills before because way back when
apparently they all split off from a
same pride which is very interesting to
me it's it's quite amazing to think that
that could be three different prides
given how successful three of them are
at the current point in time so wonder
how long that's going to last for them
to be tolerant of one another think as a
prize get bigger you might see that
they're a little bit more kind of
aggressive towards each other and
pushing each other after in a way now
you will see also and it is a very windy
day you can see the grass is rustling
all over the place and so it's making it
very difficult to actually hear anything
or pick up anything that's around us so
it sounds eerily quiet
other than the rustle of the wind
normally when we sit our chair you have
birds chirping and you'll hear the odds
kind of sound of an animal but this
afternoon it's a very eerie kind of
feeling is it's just dead silence other
than the rustling grass there's no birds
chirping and it sounds very very odd and
I wonder if that's going to make it
better for the Predators this evening as
opposed to you know if there was no wind
I'm sure it would do I mean if they walk
with the wind it's definitely going to
make life a lot easier for them rights
now before we see a feathered friend fly
off from James that send you across to
him now we've got a very interesting
bird here everybody have a look I'm
going to be quiz master The Apprentice
today oh you see that's a problem with
being a quiz master apprentice you get
things wrong you don't give fishing time
you've got him stall
David the deity who created that bird
himself would be unable to identify it
from that picture what I think we had
them is they're booted eagle and you see
there David there is the booted eagle
you could see that he had a brown head
definitely he had a pale front not quite
as pale as this but they do come in
different color morphs that's the pale
morph and then he had dark wings I say
he it could easily have been Miz's butit
Edie I mean if you look at that one we
much more closely aligned to one of
those two so possibly an immature let's
see what other pictures we can get
married and see any of that all that now
that's the picture of South Africa there
we go yes I think that's what it is
now brent Larry Smith found this booted
eagle probably the same one actually
last year so let's ask him about that
well we discover where it's gone
oh look at that we heard a very distinct
just over the wind calling so we just
moved the vehicle a little bit and we've
discovered a b sk a black shouldered cut
who looks to be in the process of
nest-building
you can hear that my black shoulder cut
impressions are absolutely horrible
quite a wonderful little Raptor that we
see quite a lot of in the Mara and
they're often seen hovering around
looking for small rodents and insects
extremely beautiful
now we're also trying to check and where
the rest of the pride are then we also
spotted another wonderful bird oh he
goes he's going oh just see how they're
just glide in the wind
lovely camera work for him aha I think
we found where the nest is now
unfortunately I'll work off quite far
from erode so the chances of us ever
coming back to this exact spot to try a
check on the nest yeah their heads taken
off and it's hanging it might even go
back into that diospyros to break off
there we go it's the pair of them
getting ready to have a few more
wonderful wonderful wonderful well we
keep an eye on them are we here but I
want to show you a freaking source first
we want to see if we can find another
member of the sausages but we spotted
another bird as well and it looked to be
a female northern white belly busted as
they call them at all fishes in Kenya
but we call them qur'an's in southern
Africa ride ahead their heads just
popping off that bush a little bit to
the right
fishes I like you know actually I think
it's a it's a female black-bellied
busted I couldn't see her clearly now
that she's stepped out can see her nice
and clearly when I just saw her head I
thought it might be a northern
white-bellied female but it's not it's a
northern black-bellied busted a black
belly busted female not a northern she's
also been hiding up amongst these rocks
on the hills and you can see that
winders started up again
now just below that nest of the black
shouldered kite or the BSK and you see
it's really rocky yes are we quite
careful yes it's another semi-invisible
lion and we can actually hold on
oh he said cries let me just
here we go oh that was a big rock and
there is another lazing line they're not
offering much better much better visit
visuals than the last but directly below
where the black shouldered kites are
building a nest
lovely views down the valley towards
Tanzania now of course it is a wonderful
day today it is world elephant day and
they are one of my favorite creatures
who I've been lucky enough to spend
hours upon hours on foot with so let's
go see some with madam mccurdy look at
how cool this is and of course I made a
mission out of the marsh
especially for world infant day how
could we not and this is actually really
really pretty the reason why we parked
the way we did is actually wanted to
show you some of the loggers look at
this now if you're unfamiliar with what
a lugger is it's basically a natural
drainage system that fills up with water
so maybe at some point it was part of an
Old River course but it has since
changed quite a bit and of course the
elephants love to live around here as
well as the Buffalo lots of water for
them to drink especially while it's so
hot at the moment probably have quite a
bit to drink in the Buffalo nights one
around and the man and the elephants
themselves and the two it's very windy
as I'm sure you can hear very very windy
it seems like it's also windy in South
Africa good kite flying weather pretty
we've got no kind of thing aren't you
ever flown a kite when he was a little
our chief in a car did you make your own
kind he made it himself look at that
what an entrepreneur but anyways it's
sad to think that in the 20th century
they were between 3 and 5 million
elephants roaming around however now in
Africa well there's only about in just
over 400,000 African elephants yet so
between the two species between all the
subspecies between the savannah elephant
which we're looking at and then of
course the forest elephant which there
are much fewer than the savannah
elephant but it is really nice to see
them in such large numbers and you're
almost guaranteed elephant sightings in
these wetland these marshy areas long as
it can be quite time they're good spots
especially now that it's dry Archie and
I were just saying that we think that
you know July supposed to be the driest
month but August this year is definitely
the driest month Patricia it's actually
the other way around when it comes to
mating and the elephant bulls come into
a state called must so essentially there
are over there's an OVA stimulation of
testosterone they get very excited and
they are constantly on the go searching
for females and east wrists
however the the elephant cows also sing
a I don't know if it's a beautiful song
they sing the Easter song which of
course will attract the males and
everywhere they've defecated and
urinated the males will be able to pick
up on these saints and sort of follow
them but they don't necessarily sort of
actively seek out a male like for
instance a leopard would like it like
you just said like a leopard would do
female and leopards are particularly
frisky elephant cows not so much most of
the time they end up running away from
the males and just every you know oh
there's a people on safari too
I've only ever seen elephants mating
once I'd love to see it again does a
spectacular scene to some wonder well
mimic experienced the herd tends to get
obviously know if it's quite if they're
excited but they trumpet a lot in there
all around you know it's obviously quite
exciting for them as well but very very
nice to see but we will have to move on
and as we've searching for lions today
and that's the most important thing we
need to find and yeah so last question
byron and elephant herds can get to very
large sizes you know they're not
necessarily all one family group so I've
seen a couple of hundred elephants
together and if they're all walking in
the same direction and on the go you
know you might find that you get lucky
and see a thousand elephants together
but typically I'd say the average sized
group is anywhere between about 20 and
50 individuals and then like I said here
there's a couple of different herds all
together but we're gonna move on now and
like I said we've got some priorities
that we need to do we need to try and
find some lions and all the river to
hunt some animals off you go to Tristan
back in South Africa who already has
this cat
we do indeed thing on is still a very
sleepy very sedate kitty at this stage
there is some impalas way way way off in
the distance behind us that we can't see
at the moment I just saw them briefly
earlier that are slowly but surely gonna
come this way they look like they're
walking this way the problem is they're
on the southern side of him so the wind
will carry his scent straight towards
him celsium but maybe that will trigger
him to start waking up and maybe doing
something I have a funny feeling though
when he does wake up he's just gonna go
straight north from here and we're not
gonna see too much of him I doubt he's
going to come south you never know that
could possibly happen so for now we're
just babysitting his sleepy kitty and
hoping that he does wake up and it does
decide to move along the boundary with
us and maybe even go down towards the
dam but if he doesn't wake up and
there's other vehicles that do want to
come here which it sounds like they are
quite a few then we might move off and
try and go see if we can catch up with
those ILI's again but Ellie's in this
kind of way there are going to be a very
difficult sighting because of the wind
howling like this
elephants often a lot more on edge and
they don't really like to be too close
to cars and things like that when it's
windy like this they prefer to be in the
thickets and have a bit of space and so
I'm not too convinced that we would
actually get a decent sighting out of
them hello tink are you going to wake up
for us boy and come on no it was close
there I thought we might even just get a
little head raise out of him but alas he
has decided it is not that time of the
day just yet
to be honest I'm actually not even sure
where the nearest water is either inside
before so I think there is a pan
straight north of us I've seen a few
lapwings flying around so it's not often
an indication especially the blacksmith
Lapwing that there is water that's not
too far I think there is a pan just
north of us to a north east
sorry waist of us at the moment then he
might head too otherwise I suppose the
dam at the nest cam area would be the
other closest water point now talking
about the nest cam
it sounds like Steve is getting involved
again with some high action of the
feathered type
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
indeed there is some high action at a
new installation on the nest cam
developments and we have got a number of
bird species down here to gray go air
birds on the left of the screen have
come down for a bit of a daily drink now
being seed eaters they need to drink
from time to time to quench that
never-ending thirst oh you see the nice
take off as they ran jumped into the
wind and off they went the wind coming
just from the bottom left of the screen
that was marvelous
we had a blacksmith leopard that
disappeared momentarily off towards the
right nice windy afternoon we are
watching deliberately to see if any
animals will come down and drink but
when it is windy like this most animals
do shy away from watching holes as it is
a little bit too jumpy and the wind is
quite scary for them because predators
often lie up and wait and as we've seen
before husana really enjoys this
watching hall where he is today we don't
know yet comes another go away bird for
a quick little drink
another one it's possibly even the same
two guys hard to say but let's see if
they use the same strategy of the wind
to take off after they leave you don't
often see birds coming down on their own
there we go look at that you don't often
have birds coming down in their own
because they're under a bit of threat
all sorts of small Raptor species are
looking for birds to come down on their
own and yes folks this is a wonderful
view Conrad has been very busy
reinstalling new different nest camps so
we get a good full aspect ratio of the
small watering hop there we go this is
the inlet side of the watering hole
where water is actually actively pumped
to provide water for the thirsty animals
and as you can see the thirsty birds
let's see how he does his takeoff
hello the Lorax you want to know when
we'll start seeing chameleons well
they're around
but generally they start sort of
reemerging as we get that there we go
look at it off he goes as we get the
foliage back on the leaves and the
insect blooms so they are around we're
just not finding them very well so they
asked they have to play around but they
tend to move into the trees and a little
bit more visible in the afternoons as
you know the after this between the
evenings when you use the spotlight but
they are around at the moment a few eggs
in the ground I'm sure somewhere but we
will definitely keep our eyes open for
you for these very camouflaged
chameleons
okay so we're going to be going over to
James Henry who has found a very small
and cute carnival yes we have everybody
there called chocolate blobs they're not
really they're called dwarf mongoose and
they are not going to be enjoying this
wind very much I must just say to you
because it's blowing on to the
Northwest's inside of their termite
mound which is not where they wanted to
blow this is the time of the day
especially on Sunday afternoon when they
like to sit on the top of their Mound
and have a little wrist for
contemplation of the week to come the
week that was and now they're being
buffeted by a very strong nor'wester you
can see that they've lived there for
some time and you can see that from the
droppings that there are on the well
basically at the bottom of the mound yes
you can just sort of see them there they
seem to be quite a few inside now is
draw comfort from these chaps because
they have such civilized hours and they
always at this time of the day look
exactly like I look to be doing exactly
what I would like to be doing which is
sitting contemplating the day with some
tea and scones perhaps or an orange cake
I've never seen them having orange cake
then
all the mad activity of the day seems to
have calmed down slightly for them
because they are very active when
they're foraging but I like this little
rest time that they have it's most
appropriate we have far no further
tracks of shadaloo the female leopard
I'm afraid but we are trying Rosalind
how fast is a dwarf Mongoose do you mean
in terms of miles per hour or kilometers
per hour
I don't really know let's think of a
human being the fastest human being can
run at an average of about 36 km/h
that's if you can run 100 meters in 10
seconds and so not many of us that can
run at 36 km/h over a sustained period
and I'm wondering if a dwarf mongooses
faster than a human being I think
probably that's sound roughly the same
speed as a human being so let's put them
in a roughly 36 km/h fast human being
that is most of us don't make it more
than 30 I don't think I think the faster
speed of human beings ever hit is about
42 km/h but that's obviously just for a
few meters all right the Ming gusta have
disappeared inside possibly because she
does the leopard it's about up here I
don't think that's the case either so
let's continue
it certainly would be lovely Emma would
be lovely if she drew the leper
disappeared I haven't found any of her
tracks I'm relatively convinced she's
still in the block where we left her
this morning and that she may well have
killed something she was hunting we
might be very lucky to see her coming
out as the Sun begins to set you may
have noticed I've put on my jacket my
put on my jacket on the count of the
fact that it's got a little bit chilly
the wind has a lot of bite to it but
certainly am i chill some edge to it
yeah put on my jacket and David's put on
his whiskers haven't you David yes
Martin his whiskers now I'm sure that
you are actually fascinated by my
discussion on Bush fashion but I think
we should go back to the Masai Mara now
not sure which Marci Mara fashion East
are we going to but I'm sure they'll
look wonderful
while James is a fascinating creature
I'll be it a slightly strange one now
we've managed to see another one of the
sausage lionesses well the best view
we've had all day since they arrived in
this thicket another flies on her
whiskers wouldn't that drive you
absolutely batty and in her mouth an
audition odds now of course the Flies
here aren't nearly as bad as what the
big cats faced in southern Africa
there's a lot more for them to hang
about on like wildebeest and their brand
but there they still do manage to get to
the big cats now as I said we've shown
you three out of the five sausages so
far now if we come into the shadow via
okay so I'm gonna go into the shadow in
there and a little bit to the right a
little bit down here we go that's a lion
behind there's a patch of grass with a
bit of green and we've got a little bit
love in there that white patch in the
bottom right hand here we go then that
is a line another two sausages
underneath that croton bush now you've
got to really work to see her through
there
and yet some view look at that all the
vultures waking up normally I'm probably
three species in there possibly only two
but it's definitely oh what's that
hello looks like a leopard faced
disappearing behind us and fortunately
and then there was some ruffles and
white backed money no lines do not stash
their kills they'll eat as much as they
can
they might lie next to their kill they
might move it into the shade to keep it
away from vultures and and how you know
so they're suppose they do stash their
kills but they're not like leopards who
will put a kill up leave it go have a
drink come back and at this time of year
they actually just leave half a carcass
lying around just because there's so
much food about
you can probably hear the wind picking
up again
Oh Patti enough to double-check this but
Patti is asking to dogs and humans both
first occur in Africa humans almost
certainly or hominins which are the pre
pre looters to humans hominins were
definitely an Afghan and therefore the
first human beings the first dogs
however I cannot be 100% sure I would
think so
I might be wrong I'm gonna have to do
some research on that Patti sorry but
the first domesticated cats not the
first cat is from Africa and that was
the African Wildcat was the first
domesticated cat and wasn't domesticated
by the ancient Egyptians but as far as I
know I'm not a hundred percent sure as I
said I'm gonna have to do some research
for you about the first the origin of
dogs and I suppose it depends what you
define as dogs modern dogs or what not
or ancient dog so jackals or what not I
actually don't know I mean to have to
find out for you since the jackals sort
of diverged and the African wild dog
diverged the earliest
it would sort of make sense that it's
probable that dogs evolved in Africa as
well okay while we search air with these
lazy lines and I have to go do some
homework let's send you back to Tristan
well good luck with your homework
Brent's and good timing because Dingaan
is just popped up his head and the
reason he's popped up his head is
because he's slowly being surrounded by
various different antelopes we had some
kuda that walked past earlier they've
disappeared to the north and then
there's some impalas that are slowly but
surely creeping up on the southern side
now has he spotted the kuda there's a
clue actually on the road now
so there's a kudu that's sitting on the
road or coming across the road and he
might have just seen those now if
there's any baby kudu it's in Ghana used
to be very good at hunting baby could is
often used to see him stalking them so
he was just kind of looking in that
direction there's a young male could do
trotting over the road and noting Ghana
doesn't seem too impressed by this he's
just flopped back down but that's
probably not what he's actually looking
for more than likely he's looking for
her son and he is looking for an
antelope because well it's much easier
to steal from her honor than it is
anything else but he's got some impalas
around some could you around there's a
lot of things happening in he might find
he'll lie like this flat because the
wind is blowing in the wrong direction
as soon as they've go past him and
pushed north of him then you might see
him wake up and start trying to stalk
and trying to come round and so I'll
just have to wait and see how this plays
out I haven't seen where the impalas
last went they last time I saw them they
were straight behind my car behind a
little thicket and I can hear ox Peck is
calling so I would imagine that they're
not too far away now there's a vehicle
that's joining us now and is around so
I'm pretty sure they're going to come in
and join us and I wonder if that will
prompt him just to pop his head up and
see what's going on
look so far he's still sleeping tired
boy this afternoon you sting gana
decided he doesn't really want to wake
up too much for us at all there's lots
of things that could stimulate him to
wake up so we'll just have to try and
wait and see if we can get this right
and hopefully he will but in the
meantime James is well with the animal
of the day and I wonder what they're up
to they are drinking the animal of the
day happy world elephant day everybody
I'm very pleased to have some elephants
on world elephant day and very happy at
world elephant day to you lot having
your drink over there I hope that you
know it's your day not sure that your
day has been any different from any
other day of course but well if this is
your day special day well done very
necessary to have these days of course
because awareness is massively important
for conservation and elephants have
received well slightly less publicity
since the scourge of rhino poaching has
dominated conservation headlines
probably for the last decade or so but
elephants also under huge pressure from
poachers from the inevitable
encroachment of human beings into wild
places
all right now I mean you can't believe
this but the nest cam is having an
exceptional afternoon today
right the nest cam is rebooting itself
so apparently it's not going to show you
some zebras we're going to continue
looking at our elephants I thought there
might come past here that's very
exciting let's hope they can pass rather
than through us I think we'll just stay
here if it's all the same to you know we
have elephants approaching us this is
wonderful hello my dear how are you
now she's quite easily recognizable from
her broken right tusks not broken it's
just short actually might be broken and
then sharpened
just gave us a little smell open to ears
very slightly and moved on with the rest
of the herd and then another big cow
bringing up the rear just looking at
David saying what a fine-looking fellow
that is peanuts Lindsey peanuts are an
elephant's favorite snack absolutely 11
and oranges peanuts and oranges I don't
think that's true I think their favorite
snack is marula fruit Lindsey
they are extremely enthusiastic about
marula fruits during marula season which
will be probably January in February
next year definitely go wild for
marilla's other than that yeah you know
they eat so much they've got such a what
we call Catholic diet you know there's
so many plants and things that they will
eat that I'm not sure it's possible to
say that they have a favorite it depends
on the area I guess but marilla's they
all love they will raid citrus farms as
well as given half the chance not these
ones aren't me citrus farms in the
kruger national park but certainly in
parts of Zimbabwe and Botswana
they will raid citrus farms where they
are not kept in fenced into wild
reserves yep a little quiet drift down
towards them excuse me to give them the
front sorry David I know that we keep
drifting forward when you get the car
and gift
a wonderful elephant bottom sighting
we're having yeah a little fin bottom
it's an elephant's head just so quiet
and they must eat and eat and eat at
this time of the year it's not easy now
in the drought year of drought of two
years ago I definitely noticed that the
elephant's lost condition no question
and this year I have not noticed the
same thing I think they're doing pretty
well they seemed to be finding quite a
lot and I think as far as dry seasons go
this one so far has been pretty
manageable of course we're only getting
to the harsh end of the dry season now
and so September and October and
November to a certain extent will be
quite telling not sure when are we going
to get our first proper rains just want
to quickly show you something else here
it's not got to do with elephants it's
at amber tea tree over here David and in
it there are some gray go away birds now
these gray go where birds are going wild
at the moment for the buds I think on
the tambour tea tree and actually need
to go and pick some so that I can see
exactly what they're going for but every
tambour tea tree that's in this budding
stage you will find grey ago where birds
in eating off the buds and I'm sure I've
seen it before but I can't remember
mentioning it before so really depends
on the year as to how long the wet
season lasts sometimes about half an
hour and other times in a good rainy
edge a little rain from sort of November
maybe early November sometimes late
October and go all the way through to
sort of March and then it'll tail or for
gained that'll be the sort of rainy
season and in this part of the world we
could expect to have about 600
millimetres of rain between 500 and 600
millimetres of rain
he's an itchy fellow and 600 mils of
rain is about five inches is it that's
not that's absolute rubbish let me just
do that again for you
600 mils of Ryan's two feet of rain two
feet of rain Hayden did you say dude
elephants ever get stuck lying down
because they fetch was that new question
eight seventy no they don't in this area
but they do they do struggle Aiden to
lie down and they struggle to get up and
I know they look like they're fat but
they're not actually fat that's just how
they built but there's a good question
you know Aiden you'll find that animals
that live in nature very seldom get fat
because well they don't eat what they're
not supposed to eat you see we human
beings eat what we're not supposed to
eat and so we get a bit fat from time to
time and if you put animals in captivity
often they do get offended not these
ones this elephants got a very itchy
bottom he's also quite curious about us
oh you biggest one fellow this always a
young bull it decides that he's going to
give us a little show of dominance
that's so special Lindsey I can't
remember you know when I get questions
like this I start to feel quite anxious
because I can't remember a particular
incident I've had so many lovely
elephant incidents and encounters some
of them on foot where the elephants have
been quite far away many of them in
vehicles most of them in vehicles but
anything when the elephant will come
around and spend time around the car
without actually interacting with the
cops or when they'll come and walk past
and just feed around there maybe just
give you the odd smell all that sort of
thing those are the best kind of
elephant interactions I think
just pop up the hill here and see we
can't have one more elephant Dave you
Jarrid yes it is possible but it's very
uncommon elephants do give birth twins
from time to time but it's not common at
all it's very unusual probably I would
suspect even more unusual than it is
with human beings so there are
definitely definitely records of
elephants giving birth to twins in the
wild but really very uncommon indeed
little one obviously not a twin and this
its twin meter sticky end but of course
in this area young calves have a pretty
good chance of making it to adulthood
not like the Predators of course who
have a dreadfully tough time getting to
adulthood and they're going to disappear
into this little river system in front
of us
and we're going to continue I have kind
of given up on shadaloo we might pop out
to where she was as the Sun Goes Down
see she comes out onto the road but
otherwise we'll look around for what
else we can find
okay let's move on David that was a much
better click I feel you know timing was
timing was good there
all right I believe that Tristan is
still with the laziest cat in all of the
sort of his hunt
well here's probably one of the laziest
surveys does pick up his head to just
show James that he's not eel is just
ever but he is still a bit lazy at the
moment and I suppose why not he does a
lot of work during the night and roams
big distances and soars and he's got a
lot of pilfering to do and so you might
as well rest before that all takes place
so it's not very very sleepy the impalas
did cross the road about two three
minutes ago and they were heading in
little thickets kind of round the back
of him so just kind of keeping an eye
out in case they make an appearance he
wasn't too interested in the kudu they
passed by unscathed luckily for them
there wasn't any young one big at all so
probably a bit large to bring down even
though he's capable that size on an
animal of that size he doesn't really do
it because it's just pretty pointless in
that he can't hoist it and so that means
that he's going to lose it to hyenas but
in Ghana in his youth used to be very
good at actually bringing down large
animals he's brought on probably some of
the biggest kills that I've seen from
leopards in his time so he's brought
down a giraffe which was pretty insane
in fact two different giraffe kills that
he made the one was a very big giraffe
and in fact he was dwarfed by the size
of it it wasn't an adult but it was
still a big individual he's brought on
two-year-old wildebeest and we've seen
our herd of wildebeest that roam around
quarantine you look at those ones that
are not even a year yet and they are big
animals so he bought two of those done
in the same day and he's taken a few odd
Fox which were big animals and a lot of
kudos and Yala's also he used to be
hunter of big big things and I suppose
as he's gotten older you know it becomes
a little slower a little more difficult
to resources and also experience has
taught him that while hunting those
things is pretty cool and it's and it's
amazing to go after those it's not ideal
from a point of view that they lose a
lot of what they kill when they kill big
animals so he'll try and steer clear of
going after things like to do and then
send her off and those kind of things
because invariably he just loses us and
the energy expense to bring them down is
not there's not equal you know the
amount of sustenance he gets out of it
so far better to go for things like an
import
she can hoist and feed off lays in the
over a few days than it is to go after
something like a giraffe where he's
gonna you know lose it very quickly so
not surprised that he kind of didn't
care too much for the could if they had
been a baby could you there would have
been a very different story
a leopard does enjoy a baby cooed II so
I didn't get the name if you can just
repeat that for me reborn so Tigana is
as far as we know I mean we don't have
an exact age it's not like asana or
tündi or you know those animals that
were born in this area that we know when
they were born and can kind of narrow it
down to a few weeks or even a few months
taganas it was a male that came in and
and theoretically we we think when he
arrived that he was about four or five
years old and given the timeline would
make him now around twelve roughly so we
think he's about twelve years old and
given his facial features in his ears
and those kind of things it very much
does look around that age so twelve
would be my guess roughly he could be a
little bit young a little bit older but
it's around that age and that's a good
age for a male lipid I mean a lot of the
male lipids here in the sabi sands will
lose condition from this age and will
then begin to start to kind of decrease
their territories and will often then
become fairly nomadic we'll take him
fuller he's a prime example of a male
leopard that actually became less
dominant as he got older and most of the
male lipids do do this we saw with
campaign
Tyson Matheny and Joe Don all of these
guys as they get to around twelve
thirteen
they started in relinquish their
territories a little bit for younger
individuals that will start to come into
these areas and take over they pretend
they're healthier they were able to
patrol more and so you see these kind of
things happen and you end up with that
with you know these guys didn't being
pulled out so he's getting to the
twilights of his career no doubt I mean
no one's under any false pretenses and
it'll be a sad day when he's not the
dominant male but hopefully he can be
much like in Lula and that he can
somehow figure out a way between
everybody so that there's no issues when
it comes to
you know figure out a way to kind of be
nomadic around it when he doesn't
actually get himself into a bad
situation where he has to fight with
somebody and get badly injured that's
what I'm hoping anyway it's obviously
doesn't always happen that way and you
know sometimes wonder which is worse is
it's worse when the male lipid at the
end of his life gets attacked by another
male and it's over quickly always a
twist when you see something like you
know who ended up just wasting away and
kind of starving to death rather than
actually being you know fighting his way
and dying by the kind of sword he lived
by and just living in what challenging
for a territory so I don't know if it's
a mixed feeling it's always sad either
way when a big old male lipid disappears
from an area so hopefully that won't be
anytime soon I'm hoping Tigana can cling
on for another year year and a half and
it would be ideal yeah certainly a lot
of time for husana to stay in this area
don't know why maybe maybe it's much
like people and that's the lazier they
are the you know they miss they feel
like what at least physical activity
they do they've lazier they become I'm
not quite sure it's an interesting
observation I don't think so I think
it's more age-related as the older they
get often lazier they become although
there were some individuals that were
you know old that used to still walk a
lot I remember you know watching Tyson
when he got a bit all day he still moved
quite a bit and still did quite a lot
and went all over the show and so you
know it's it's an interesting kind of
take on I don't know let's look at Tandy
she certainly is not showing her age 12
she's still very mobile and Musil are
all over the place ting gana is much the
same he's also very much like that he
moves quite a bit and does quite a lot
and really kind of missions around even
at his age down in pula well he was a
big Walker as well but slowed right down
towards the twilight of his career so I
remember the one day with him Villa he
was seen on the Sand River in the
morning and by that afternoon was
crossing into manulito which is a
a long long long place he's used to walk
a long way and kind of was interesting
just to see how he's slowed right down
towards then be used to make much
shorter walks and it's more an
age-related thing you probably find his
body gets SOI it's you know joints gets
all muscle is wasting a little bit so it
makes it much harder for him to be able
to actually do what he needs to do so
it's a tough thing you know getting old
is not easy
as I'm sure many of us can it taste you
it does make life a little bit more
difficult and being physically active as
you get older is not always that easy
there's a hard life Dingaan you can see
a big kind of deep rate as he's just
sitting there hoping now the Sun is
starting to go down so pretty sure that
we're getting to that time of the day
where he's going to start waking up and
you just popped his head up because of a
branch that's one of the guys just drove
over so it's new eyes kind of done
that's there are some impalas there they
go they're just going across the road
now so you'll see some of our antennas
but there goes an Impala just
disappearing over there so not too far
that's the last of the impalas that I've
seen that there might be one more but
they've just crossed a little bit too
far I think for Dingaan it's actually
have realized that they were they're
quite nice now everybody's left us again
and it's peaceful and quiet right well
taganas still sleeping which is pretty
par for the course of soft you know it
sounds like James apparently is still
also bumbling about and I'm hoping that
he'll get some luck that should do Lou
as the evening closes in
yes I'm hoping desperately that I'm
going to get some luck unfortunately I
haven't had any at the moment all stop
press there's a cape Turtledove it's
gone you've seen their luck at all now I
must just tell you a funny story as we
were coming down this road last during
our rehearsal for the TV shows this was
on Friday morning so two morning's ago
we came just around this corner and I
thought I saw a puff adder on the side
of the road and I said to Craig he was
on camera Craig there's a puff adder on
the side of the road he said no no it's
a zebra carcass and it was tingling
which I thought was quite amusing
kangana resembles a carcass at the
moment of his refusal to get happen do
anything other than sleep or steal food
yes I thought so to 'martha was easily
10 Ghana can easily be confused with a
puff adder and or a zebra carcass listen
we've had a number of interesting
misidentifications craig spotted a Genet
in a tree once and said there's Columba
i'm just quite funny i think i called a
scrub here a buffalo I don't know how I
managed to get that wrong anyway please
we're seeing things you know whether or
not we're identifying them properly in
the darkness is another matter what
we've done is we've come further east to
see if we can't pick up something else
we gave up in the West where should do
Lou was oh look at this is David the two
amigos which one do you want the back
that one is that all right let me get
out of the way don't forget to click
when you come back to me
beautifully backlit gnarled you'll see
little strings
citrus colors like that citrus colors
infusing his fight mental
and again that Sunday peacefulness was
that an intentional wreck focused over
nobody nice it's going to say David I
didn't think that that was a
particularly entertaining stick to be
looking at but you know it's up to you
you're the artist here I'm just here to
interpret what you shoot you can hear no
birdsong at all
just one Franklin calling in the far
distance and he'll be able to hear the
wind whistling through the tops of this
Torchwood tree above us my goodness
gracious me we're going to go across to
the nest camera now it's having an
afternoon of extreme action
now it seems like there's a few gremlins
that are art in a baton so you're back
with us and hitting honor that's rolled
over since you've last seen him I'm
thinking he might wake up at some point
and the reason why I say that is because
there's a vehicle not too far away
that's got enough flat tire and so
they're having to change their tire and
I'm wondering if maybe just maybe the
noise of a tire being jacked and taken
off and all those kind of things we'll
be able to actually wake our sleepy Duke
up because the Sun is setting it's that
time of the day where he should
theoretically be starting to wake up as
you can see that beautiful isn't it
perfect winter sunset you often get
these very orange sunsets in winter and
that's all because of the amount of dust
in the air as well as often the fires
that have been little all over the place
that's a little bit of smoke to go up
and the filters that Sun and just makes
it a little bit more kind of in whatever
the word be diffused is probably the
best word for it so it's a nice kind of
soft coloration that you get in the
winter months which is ways very very
pleasant you know like I said I hope
that that's going to wake up the jus
because it's gotten to that time in the
day we should start leaving his tummy is
very full I wonder if he didn't steal
some form of a carcass or kill something
last nights because he kind of came
following Tandy's Shack so we know that
she had a small Stan book but I think
there was not very much left by the time
Tania and Columbia at fiddleford so it
can't really be them and this they
killed something else or he managed to
find himself his own meal in Hoover it
down as quick as possible one thing I
have noticed with Dingaan over the past
few weeks of following him around which
has been a delight is that he can put
away a serious amount of food in a
single sitting I watched him the other
day with that Impala carcass and also at
the duiker carcass where he got up into
a tree and he literally Hoover dam the
entire carcass there was a died care
that he had just close to the camp when
we were doing I think was during one of
our rehearsals maybe last week Friday a
week before Friday and and he just ate
the whole hiker
which is pretty impressive and we've
seen most of the dike is that was on it
has killed has been at least a two-day
affair but he just ate at all so could
have been something like that that
Hoover down is definitely and I swell to
that Bailey which is always a good thing
and whether or not it's he took it or
killed it himself doesn't really matter
either way it's a good sign for the
aging Duke when you see him with the
fool Bailey never really wanted to see
him going back to what we saw at the
beginning of this year it was quite sad
actually and I was looking at some
footage and some pictures that I had of
him from in January February March and
it really was it he's a shadow of what
he is now he was skinny he looked
emaciated and he just looked tired and
old and really not himself and then as
things have now kind of gone he's made
this miraculous comeback where he really
does look back into good shape and yeah
is showing a little bit more signs of
age that's for sure I just had some
pictures that I was looking at from 2016
2015 and he definitely looked a lot kind
of young and fitter but I suppose you
know two years is a long time in a
lipids life and definitely a few more
Nicks and cuts on the ears and a little
bit more whites around the face and you
know that's kind of hard guys I suppose
but also it's interesting with him is
that his julep seems to continue to grow
it's still very big and I had to giggle
because I was looking at the footage we
had of him the other day when he had
that Impala in the knob thorn tree which
he stole from tanyon Colombo which was I
think last week Thursday or Wednesday
last week and there was a point where he
was cleaning his paws and I can't
remember if we were live or not but he
was cleaning his paws on this tree and
he was kind of leaning down and forward
at a 45 degree angle to the ground and
because of it the skin on his neck and
julep was falling forward and he almost
looked like what is the name of those
dogs that gets was pug like in a way
because all of his julep folded skin had
kind of flapped down past his jaws and
was all rolled up around his face it was
very comical to see I was trying to find
a picture of it and I'll try and show
all of you what I'm talking about but it
was very very funny to see it's just
kind of more and more skin is being
added around that face and stretched out
as he's gotten older he surely has to
have one of the biggest juleps out of
all the lipids that we see up here she
in general in the sabi sands it's a
really big big
well-developed unit
that he's got it makes his head and neck
look really good so I suppose that's
also quite quite intimidating to other
lipids that are roam around here
Pisces Bobby not really yet I mean his
it's a really cool day I am actually
dreading the fact that I left my jersey
at home it means it's going to be a very
cold afternoon for me but it's it's
quite cool the wind is cold and so lying
in the Sun I think was actually quite
nice for him I think he was absorbing a
little bit of sunshine and staying
fairly warm on a blustery cool afternoon
and it's not a surprise that he's out in
the open like this with a full belly
he's not actively looking to hunt and
being the relaxed Duke he doesn't really
have to go in line a thicket he's not
kind of hiding from anybody or hiding
from any prey animals he's just resting
and sleeping and so he kind of probably
found that he walked quite far today and
found this little comfy spot of grass
with little bits of shade from this
small tree and decided well I'm gonna
lie down right here and enjoy my nap for
the afternoon and so that's probably
what's happened he was left quite far
from here actually this morning there
guys said to me that they left him on
the northern side of Bulls of dam inside
worthless hook so he came back onto the
boundary and walked all the way
westwards
and then obviously during the day and
then decided this is where he's gonna
race so I'm not surprised that he is
quite tired and taking it very easy but
you know it's also it looks really out
in the open because of where we parked
we're in close proximity to Emily you
know only what 10 15 meters from where
he is and you know he could easily be
missed if you drove along the road right
well from one sleepy cat that is kind of
hidden in the gardening Prince Leo Smith
is searching around for other sleepy
cats that potentially also hiding out in
the long grass of the Maasai Mara well
we've decided to abandon the sausages
they don't look like they're moving
sorry I know we don't normally wear
sunglasses but the dashed coming off the
road
she might even see so I'm gonna put my
glasses on you can see we passing quite
a lot of a vault of Easterns ever as we
go it is quite a lovely afternoon here
in the Mara apart from the Harlan Gale
of course so we decided we're gonna
start heading home we left camp just
before 5:00 this morning so twelve hours
of sexy where we found the Lions this
morning they were right next to this
little waterhole lying over there talus
would like snow there's dust act as an
actual sunscreen I suppose yes it does
Tanis but it also acts as a natural eye
irritant and nostril irritant is quite
irritating but yes I suppose it would
true degree actors a bit of a natural
sunscreen after days like this up in the
field when you have a shine you actually
wash your hair the water turns
completely Brown that's how much dust is
it and also because we in the Mara and
this is all volcanic soils it is so fine
it gets in everywhere in your teeth in
our breakfast boiled eggs this morning
we had free Mara dust with that with
them we try to put salt on them but the
salt blew away so yeah there's a lot of
dust at the moment what hasn't rained
for a couple of days we're gonna trying
to head out oh here we go
we're there now and the worst thing is
when you see one of these guys coming at
you like a bloody rage if not you got to
get prepared
for the dust storm that's coming where
my dust goggles I couldn't find them
earlier now the reason I'm wearing my oh
the Fortuner winds action won't valdi
take your life enjoy enhance the winds
actually doing us a favor this time
passing away oh no there's another car
coming it's traffic traffic in the mire
okay well hopefully I'll see you just
thoughts I've got past all the dust in
the meantime let's go to a man who I
know probably hates dust more than I do
amongst many other things James injury
oh yeah I don't mind dust it's the
diesel I minded when I was there in the
Mara it is very difficult driving of the
wind behind you because diesel and dust
form a cloud around you and that's what
you inhale the whole time anyway we
don't have any diesel or - yeah we've
just got the sunset going down there on
this Sunday afternoon here a world
elephant day never differences in Sun
I'm not pretty well done David excellent
job as usual I do love how David Guiteau
spends a great deal of time
congratulating his cameraman and I think
it's a good idea otherwise they get a
bit testy these fellows you know the
sun's getting down on another week David
Sunday afternoon come into a clause you
don't know why I'm talking like that
will stop immediately very pretty you
can see the wind still blowing not as
hard as it is in the Masai Mara is
blowing and we're heading towards twin
dams hoping to find whatever we can at
twin dams pretty much goal lists at the
stage because we haven't managed to find
what
set out to and that was shedule norther
I found any other lipid attracts this is
my face of shame why are you laughing in
my face have shamed it it's not funny at
all it's my face of shame
they also noticed that my jacket has got
a number of them strange lesions on it I
think it was ironed by mistake odd okay
it doesn't actually look too bad on
camera
it's worse than real that and there it's
not our deal Thank You Emma I agree with
you and they have to purchase another
one also my blanket into a jacket that's
public good idea
let's pull up onto the dam wall here and
see what we can find
hang on a second I'll tell you what I
would like to do is get a little bit of
jackal berry fruit action I think all
moons have taken the jackal berry fruits
let's see if we can find one here's one
now mr. husk like the word husk David
it's quite nice to say husk try they've
all been absolutely devoured now here's
one here too itchy have you ever had one
David I'm sure you have here we go
don't worry that it's been in the mouth
of a baboon I wouldn't bite on that end
I'd bite on this end okay peel it a bit
and then just take the fruit hmm that's
very nice
it's quite a sticky normally much
sweeter than this one is excuse me
it is horrible
they're actually normally very nice and
not surprise the baboon rejected that
one it was a very effective sweetness
followed closely by a it was like
somebody had stuffed of dust filled
vacuum cleaner into my mouth and turned
it on to blow alright well thank
goodness David bought 10 liters of water
and drive with him hmm right Brent has
managed to find in amongst his cloud of
diesel and dust the great king of the
jungle and I'm not referring to him of
course well it's not the sausage tree
pride it's almost the exact same spot I
had yesterday evening and morning here's
the little boy so they only ate a small
canoe last night so they are still
looking quite hungry
isn't he have impressed with whiskers on
him they're awesome wildebeest not too
far away
and the others are quite far off I've
lost sight of them that oh she smiles
away so there's that fella nighties tree
right next to the main road there here
we go
there's one there we come to the left a
little bit there should be another was
it to the right you know they are gone
edition so it's quite far left or the
other one there we get back right
slightly there we get there she is but
this girl looks like she's gonna walk
right next to us hello oh we know I know
where'd the go go little boy a young
female young female I think I know a
little girl okay let's just go back a
little bit
and see the see where she's going now
there is a missing lioness and I've
noticed the Lions and the Mara will
often use these big drains while their
hunt keeps them below the eyeline same
as they would use a a little riverbed or
a stream now this is the young lioness
oh not one of the adults and not one of
the more experienced one so it's gonna
be interesting to see what she gets up
to you can see this and wildebeest over
there there's one there there's one even
closer to the road quite often as I said
they'll lie in the road using it as
cover oh this is what often happens at
this time of the year when there's so
much food around those ones have spotted
the lines behind us you can see they're
on high alert which could work to our
young girls advantage so there's that
young boy behind owner there's a lioness
coming across the open behind us and
they've seen her now that could really
work to her advantage because a lot of
the focus is now going to be on the the
others that are actually behind and none
of them have noticed her just yet
now mrs. Anna is wondering who are the
male coalition's that lead the we know
pride that is a very good question we've
seen them with the triangle boys before
all that kit right ember
males as they're called but what I've
noticed in the Mara is that anything
goes
I've seen the sausage tree pride mate
with obviously key pulley the two young
boys and then they were also mating with
some completely unknown male that came
through from the South another skittish
aggressive male oh you're in the wrong
spot girl you wanted to be right under
his schnoz he tried to cross the road
and as he now spotted you think he has
but she seems more focused on different
Valda beasts
Nariko is wondering are they taking
positions to get ready to hunt well she
is in Miss remember she's she's not too
much of a a year and a half maybe a
little bit older so she's not the most
experienced the big girls are miles away
five six hundred metres behind us the
ones that do most of the hunting she
might have just got bored now there is a
line of all the beasts coming because
they spotted the Lions behind us off to
the left that might walk straight into
the area where she is
there they go
no yeah we're there let's go no yes no
strange creatures wildly beasts but I
think her inexperience is going to count
up account against this evening as well
could look me see if there's any more
lions appearing yet not yet
I think I've accidentally pulled my
comms out sorry about that
let's just keep an eye on these well
these well know she's watching them
carefully them did you get those comms
hi joy joy one of the biggest
misconceptions created by the Lion King
is that wonderful movie is it was it was
created so many bad ideas about wild
animals no male lions do not lead the
pride and neither do females the prides
quite democratic and no one's really the
boss they're just sort of a unit however
with males males will have multiple
prides of females if they are able that
they will mate with the more females
they can have the more they can spread
their genetic code which is what they
progress program to do now while we on
the fallacies of the Lion King oh
something's going on I can't see why
she's running where you going
did your mom call you back well you're
being a naughty little girl okay don't
know what's happened I think one of the
adults might have started calling we
can't really hear anything in this
whoopsy sorry that's a big bump I was
watching the line in this wind oh she's
gonna pop I think she's gone yeah as I
suspected she wasn't seriously hunting
more bored and playing and looks like
she's gone to play with the other Lions
now it's not uncommon to see them doing
this during the migration they sort of
know if they really want you they don't
have to go far and they'll catch
something there'll be one slightly
ailing wildebeest somewhere so she just
went to go pounce upon some of the other
Lions here we go three out of five are
we knows and so guys we're a hundred
percent live I just want to show you a
car in front of us quickly now that is
the Michigan State University hyena
researchers they are the best at getting
stuck in the Mara they also get stuck
everywhere and on anything at all times
so hi guys we've had to rescue them a
few times and if they're not stuck the
battery won't work in their car so we
find them across the Mara all over the
place so of course they've been a
massive help to us with the
identifications of the North clan and
the happy zebra clan and there are
definitely good fun even when they do
get stuck they are in good spirits Jaime
even rescued them one night after they
had to spend the whole night in the car
but as I think these are we knows are
not going to hunt just yet I'm gonna
keep heading north woods towards home
and it's been quite a long day and it
looks like it's been a long day for the
oh we know pride as well
well from these lazy cats to another
lazy cat all the way back in South
Africa Dingaan indeed
he's been the laziest of lazy cats this
afternoon I really would have thought by
now he would have woken up at least just
put his head up to look around but he
has not done anything we even had
Franklin's bursting out of the bushes
and squealing and making noise and he
didn't even flinch so he's obviously
decided he's going to sleep long into
the evening and probably find that ting
Ghana is going to decide to wake up one
minute before we probably finished this
evening that's a normal trick 14 gallons
Wow you have often find him so late in
the drive is because had he been in a
thicket or a we couldn't see him and you
find that he only starts to walk and
actually wake up just as our drive start
to finish a lot of the time so not ideal
but we will be patients I mean we've got
a little bit of time stool and hopefully
he will wake up in the next little bit
definitely hasn't not one vehicle has
caused him to stir or anything like that
is still very much asleep at this stage
yes for certain Ghana time for you to
wake up way I think we've been patient
this afternoon a different he has been
an exercise in waiting for an animal to
wake up and you know often Lions get a
bad read before sleeping a long period
of time but lipids sometimes done the
same and sometimes can sleep for quite
long periods as well Nancy you saying
you go to Ghana you do your thing
well yes exactly I mean he's a dominant
male leopard and so rest is in order in
order to be able to kind of keep up with
the times and make sure that he's fit
and healthy and is able to patrol and
get to all the places he needs to go and
so having a good nap is nothing wrong
with that it's just it would be nice if
we could just get his head up for a few
minutes just so that we could see his
beautiful eyes he's got such a nice pair
of eyes does ting Ghana there's kind of
ACMA aquamarine color in at times and so
I always enjoy kind of when he's looking
is although he does have a bit of a
dopey face when he is sleepy like this
it's quite funny when he's
had a lot to eat Inez but sleepy he does
have one of the dopiest faces out of any
of our lipids not like his son who's
always got wide eyed and bushy tail in
the form of wasana he was running around
all over the place and wonder where he
is it's been kind of two days since
we've seen a sauna which is not normal
fast I mean we normally get lucky and we
were able to find him some ways
hopefully he's going to be around I
wonder I think he's got to kill some
ways what I think is that when we last
saw him he managed to find himself a
meal which was yesterday morning and
that's where he's sitting that's at
least what I firmly believe but he's
such an active hunting cat that it would
be sort of quite difficult to think that
he hasn't appeared somewhere if he
wasn't sitting on a carcass you know he
walks around too much and is too busy
when he is looking for food that we
would have picked up a sign of him in
some place so the rain has made it
really difficult it's know it sounds odd
because we didn't have much rain I mean
we only ended up I think having about
three millimeters of rain over two days
but it was just enough to cake or just
to wet the surface of the soil and
really cake it together and make it hard
and I promise you to seeing lipid tracks
at the moment is really not easy at all
the road surfaces are still need to be
broken up again with cars and make them
soft and even the the areas off the road
the animals need to walk through again
and just dust it all up in a bit of cold
windy or dry windy conditions should I
say it also needs to kind of come in and
just to get everything that nice soft
powder again so that we can see very
easily and once that happens and I think
we'll pick up personna pretty quickly
but I'm sure he's going to make an
appearance at the dam cam again in the
next few days and it's
no it's just it's just an update I was
just trying to hear it sounds like
there's two wild dogs and some any
liquid with a kill somewhere but I can't
hear where it sounds like maybe in the
east somewhere maybe in Korra or
somewhere like that it's difficult to
pick up with so much when the guy is
speaking with is just his radio is
muffled I'm short James maybe we've got
a better update then I did but it sounds
like some ways something amazing is
happening there's lots going on all
around us I suppose and it's you know we
can't have all the action on our side
all the time we've been so fortunate
over the last few weeks because we've
had non-stop I mean we really haven't
had it very difficult to have we we've
been fortunate in having a lot of
content and a lot of things happening on
Numa pretty regularly over the past few
weeks and like I say our Sun has kind of
been the star of that show but this was
have been dogs we've had them cool my
pride back Dingaan has been around tani
calamba she didn't even make an
appearance today and I'm must be honest
I was a bit jealous this morning because
the last night I got a phone call from a
friend saying that shadaloo was mobile
east towards our boundary so when I came
down this morning to do the nest cam
that I told James whacked me with just
driving with Alexis and she might be
there and he drove up an infant should
do this you know walking down the road
and I haven't seen her since I've been
back from Amara so the last time I saw
sir Denis was in in March end of March
so I'm quite looking forward to seeing
her again it's been a very long time I
quite enjoy spending time with her she's
such a busy cat then it's always a
pleasure to follow her around often
posing in great places and kind of
making herself available for many many
different photographic opportunities as
well it's just she always kind of is up
to something so I enjoy it I know this
morning she didn't move that much but
she was hunting her bunion so you know
she was she was a focused cat this
morning which is unusual for her because
generally she's all over the place and
moving around so I would like to see her
again I'd spin so long it's always good
to catch up with her who else happened
to be seen Tumbo would be nice to him
for him to come back no updates on him
though and unfortunately still nothing
since a few weeks ago so it would be
nice if we could get something on our
little boy as well and
he makes an appearance again at some
points it's getting more and more
unlikely that he will but you never know
one can always hope
who else haven't we seen much of kochava
mist
well mr. Q as well quarantine would be
nice for him to pop out at some points
and even how come where he has been
rather absent of late so I've got a lot
of liquids to catch up with since I've
went away hopefully they all start to
make an appearance but we can't complain
like I said we've had such a good time
recently with leopard there's been
pretty much daily that we have had them
so gremlin general I want to know are
you one that is going to be removing
gremlins from now on from our systems
because if that's the case then you are
most welcome to do so
gremlins are a pain in our backside so
hopefully you will be able to command
them and get rid of them but ting Anna
does sleep a lot yes because he's
getting older but also because of his
condition that he's in right now so he's
full he's healthy there's no reason for
him to be out hunting at the moment this
morning he was patrolling he soared this
morning say announced his territory so
he's not ready you've got a reason and
there's not many males that are pushing
him at the moment you know since he's
been up and moving and talking and
making a lot of noise who come where
he's not put up much of a fight he's
decided no ways am i dealing with this
angry leopard that he's walking around
making so much noise and so you know
he's kind of asserted himself back again
so suppose he can be fairly happy in the
fact that he's got a female who's
currently got a cub he's got you know
access to food and water is he's in a
healthy condition his belly is full and
so no need to march too much and no need
to really move around that much so he
can have a nice little nap and have a
bit of a steep but I do think he'll wake
up I mean I think it might take him in
the next 15 20 minutes but I think now
is the time where he's gonna start
staring you can really see he's moving a
little bit right now it sounds like
James has found something so we can
quickly send you across to him
oh my goodness well at least you've got
a brief flash there how dare they walk
off the road there
those are Shelley's Franklin's everybody
and I know that we mentioned the
Shelley's Frankenstein but we seldom
show you the Shelley's Franklin we just
did there they were sitting perfectly
pressed on the road and then decided to
go away let's continue we were having
one last sort of scratch about where we
saw shedule and you did get them at the
beginning well that's good hello
shelli's Franklin's yesterday yeah well
doesn't know yet to do that all you have
to do is shout Shelly's Franklin and
them arrive one on the left of us is
well David look it's been left behind
separated from its family from the rest
of its cubby there we go we'll be out of
here very shortly you got it there doh
middle of screen they are up a bit said
bird there we get thing with a beak
that's it I tell you I think the
Franklin's have some of those beautiful
feathering plumage it is not quite as
bright as that it's a hyacinth macaw for
example but it's got such a subtle
beauty to it shiny detailed colors
bronzes and golds and oranges it is it's
in front of us now again it's the
feather thing walking through the grass
there was the beak there we are it's
going to come across the road you
shouldn't miss it there come on now I'm
to the road yeah we go there pretty I
think that girl just yes your friends
went in there they're waiting for you
they're delicious meal waiting for you
I'm sure roasted seeds perhaps one of
them's flown away
let's go a little bit more difficult to
find now alrighty on the go
davidís of course scanning with the free
year to try and find do lose heat
signature scenic the fastest little
critter that we have here well I mean
other than the cheetah you mean I
suppose if we talking about things other
than mammals that would be the solid
fusion the solid fuge is an arachnid
that looks terrifying isn't totally
harmless but they have an amazing
ability to run at great speed so I'm
gonna go with the Sola fuge read Romans
spider they're sometimes called they're
not spiders at all and they hunt will
these vicious I've forgotten the proper
name for them now basically mandibles
nasty tooth - mandibles they saw that
their prey with really not a nice way to
go but they're very quick yes I don't
think there are the pedipalps Louise I
think they are the pedipalps on either
side of those two nasty teeth anyway
I'll have a look might be might be
pedipalps I'm gonna have to turn some
lights on now there we are I'm not
nocturnal I cannot see in the dark
David can you see in the dark
clearly not
as evidenced by your ability to see that
feathered thing that was running past us
anyway I don't blame you I can't see in
the dark either you might even have to
retrieve a spotlight oh ah the chalice
array that's what we're going for
Thank You Louise the chalice array has
got some vicious barbed chilla serenely
AE and they they rub together like this
and saw their prey in half and then in
quarters and then eighths and sixteenths
32 64 128 256
512 1080 foots 2048
I'm sure I've gone wrong something yes
Thank You Emma Emma says we should do
that for the kids sure I think it's a
really good idea if the solar fusion
were to cut this termite in half and
then in half again what would we have a
culture of a termite sir correct John
and Billy if we were to cut the termite
again in half what would we have the
sixteenth of a termite sir well done
Billy no Amy maybe we would cut the
termite in half again what would we have
oh that's easy sir one thirty second
very good Amy and you Wayne if we were
to cut it in half again what did we have
not a lot of termites
very correct Wayne is not a mass boffin
clearly
these are the things we must talk about
when looking in the night for creatures
that might be active David you found us
anything with your feet a thermal camera
you have to keep it on me it was alive
I think this live world Wayne poor old
Wayne I think there's a Wayne in every
classroom
yes and emili´s is you better be careful
not to insult our viewers called Wayne
yes I learned mean to insult you
yes indeed oh right I think this is
wonderful news I believe that the son of
the Duke husana has arrived the dam can
we're going to make our way there at
some speed and while we motor there well
you're going to stay with us suppose
here we go
vroom vroom good much better idea let's
go crossed just well good luck James may
speed be with you and safe driving and
Wendy do does not give you any hassles
on your way to the dam kam and we called
it at some point that she'll get to the
dam cam and I'm pretty sure he has it
kill somewhere I had checks for him in
the Milwaukee yesterday I wonder if
there's not a little duiker sitting in a
tree somewhere along that Milwaukee
system and he's now that's coming for an
evening drink before heading back
towards his killer I think that might be
the case actually
but either way very exciting and always
good to hear that the little prince is
still well in the area that he should be
right in the center of Jim it makes all
of us very happy
Tenggara is not at all fazed by this
news as you can see he's not that
excited sangani you must be excited the
little prince is back no it's still
nothing I asked him it he didn't really
want to lift his head you will find
probably hurt in Ghana they at some
point if there's food King Ghana will
sniff it out that's for sure that nose
will be down to the ground and trying to
find it I hope that it doesn't happen
because hasana deserves a whole meal
from start to finish for himself
particular big-ish one because well he's
had pretty much all of them robbed by
various family members over the past few
weeks and so I'm hoping that he used to
sneak have it off to himself so he won't
speak too loud about food around in
Ghana because that might wake him up and
he'll go strutting off to go and steal
it and to take it for himself which I
know we joke around about it I really
shouldn't actually joke he's known to
hate in Ghana anybody because he's just
doing what any lipid would do there's
nothing wrong with the fact that he
takes these kills and like I say
indirectly it is perfectly fine because
as long as he takes a killing his
tolerance of wasana means that hosanna
gets to stay and doesn't have to fight
with any other
and Mail lipids in order to find a
territory and therefore is in lot safer
than if he was walking around in areas
like gondolas in places like that so as
much as it is always tough for little
husana who looks up and gazes upon his
dad eating his meal it's the best thing
because it means he doesn't have to
worry about kind of losing out to other
big males and having to actually fight
with anybody to get safety now I wonder
if Hasan I mean Tigana would actually
even wake up this evening I thought by
now we would at least have a head upward
yeah flicking or some sort of twitch but
well as you can see zero is happening in
fact his I don't think he's even moved
in here in the last 20 minutes we went
for a little tinkle and earlier to try
and kind of see if we could just relieve
the bladders and he didn't wake up for
that either when we went across the road
anyway the send you across to Steve who
I believe is on the nest cam and I
wonder if the little prince is going to
make an appearance on the nice cam see
him I think I am on the right one Emma
can tell me if I am NOT the damn cam has
spotted him and he is mobile
towards the dam hello everybody we are
looking for Hassan I haven't quite seen
him yet but we are on the nest cam once
again and hoping to spot him moving
towards and the damn cameras spotted him
not sure where he is folks but we can
only stand by here and watch with that
now the installation of this side of the
dam in a watering hole we are able to
see things coming up on the side and
right in front of us with this rock
sized wheel sonic killed the daycare
only weeks ago and this is a very good
spot so hopefully I can't see what's
going on in the dam can but hopefully he
is making his way up here at the moment
which could be quite exciting to reveal
him on the nest cam this afternoon okay
well while we change our angle James is
on his way in to come and have a look at
a sauna and
come right back yeah cuz I know that I
didn't even know that she was with him
are we live hello we're live we're just
hitting down as fast as we can towards
what is that on the road is that a
duiker no yes it is
Spica bleed acre it's just gone into the
bush there we are driving as fast as we
can but in the safe and responsible
manner of course to the dam you can see
if we can't find hassan ah is he still
on the dam cam emma is he stood on the
dam camp Oh fantastic
nearly there when you say he's walking
away I met you mean that he's going east
west north of that
- awesome bundle good towards them
fumble we all go we're on our way
towards and bumbu are you enjoying your
ride everybody I hope that you are not
sitting with a drink in your lap because
it'll be all over your clothes by now
here we go about to drop into
second-year four-wheel drift around this
corner are you holding on David here we
go whoa no we'll have to slow down as an
Impala that's because we're being
responsible you see and a wildebeest
there we go
oh they really got in there Texans got
him just found him
sorry don't you just try and get hold of
him
tax I didn't hear you calling sorry
where's he gone he's gone North found
quite a long way away okay never mind
we should get lucky he's crossed over
there's no way is he gonna get him on
the nest right now isn't
close to the jackal Barry going more to
the north right well let's keep going
then you take a year to get it over the
damn wall yeah all right let's get back
to Tristan while we try and figure out
what's going on over here
well good luck James hopefully you'll
figure it out
we've just left Dingaan and now he's
still very very sleepy and we thought -
it's just try and see if there's
anything else about before we head off
down back towards camp and I was
wondering if maybe just maybe Tandy or
Colombo I was around I was thinking that
we'll have a little sort of look and see
if there's anything happening but
doesn't seem like anything as always
Gary Kaplan is a great road to drive for
tiny and Columba they often just pop up
here in the most random times so it's
worth just having a little look and like
I said it's in Ghana being as sleepy as
he is we gave it a good shot but he
still hadn't even twitched by the time
we left and so I thought snow will just
carry on and see if we can't whip out
something else maybe we get lucky and
we'll find something like a mansion a
Pangolin a penguin would be good I
haven't seen a penguin in a long time
come on penguin come out that would be
nice I saw somebody saw an aardvark in
the last few days I think was in the
western sector and there's also been a
few penguins been seen to our west and
our south it would be quite nice for
what you know of those species to come
out I always say this every night
drivers though it's going to happen and
that we're going to find it so we never
really do but I'm hoping that's like
some miracle a one will pop outs at some
points and we can actually show you guys
property I know we have seen a Pangolin
before on our drives which is always
exciting but it was not easy to get a
proper view of it so I really like one
to be on a road or something like that
forward of you because they're just the
most fascinating creatures and obviously
highly highly endangered
being trafficked at a rate at not so it
would be really good to actually find
them oh hello do you want to jump on
board we know somebody would like to
meet you it's going to run away but
there was a duiker that was standing
there and that would be perfect meal for
hassan edwin sure james would love to
have that duiker with him now because
well it sounds like he's still looking
for her sana
I am doing my best everybody for the
last minute while we try and find our
old prince II see it almost seems to me
that when I want to turn left at the
next Junction the junction was always
100 miles from where I wanted to be here
we go he was apparently heading down
here towards this area Texan couldn't
follow him
[Music]
we have 60 seconds left I'm afraid to
find him we have had a leper today so
that's why we might be lucky around here
David any luck with your fever all right
I'm gonna stop here and hope that he
pops out perhaps on this game path over
here can hear some birds alarming
everybody if we don't see them now
hopefully we'll see him tomorrow we will
be live of course at 6:30 Central
African time until 8:30 tomorrow Central
African time thank you for joining us
today thank of your questions and
comments and I hope you enjoy the rest
of your weekend until tomorrow morning
goodbye